for your recording going and then we'll
get our basics coming here it's we are
recording we are pretty much good let me
lower my mic and just my button my chair
a little bit here we got some talking
alright umm yes let's do it
give me the call man give me the signal
I'll give you the countdown mm-hmm
what's up par 5 3 2 1 all right the last
word with Yvonne tiss and we are live we
got a lot to talk about we got a lot to
digest man oh man I'm disheveled I'm
operating on no sleeve but I don't care
but he's a trooper out here in these out
here I don't know yeah but I don't care
but GS wow wow there's a lot to unpack
here he what's going on man what is
going on so got a workout in squeezed it
in before all this started driving home
like let me see if I can get a haircut
crap Google stadia starts I'm literally
getting my hair cut being the rudest
person in the world I already apologized
to the person cut my hair watching
literally watching the stadia thing go
on I was like I know something's gonna
be in here I know something's gonna be
here they're like founders edition
I'm sorry comes with what stadia
started it early which is why they had
their timing that way so Stadium in
early we'll get into that in a little
bit so founders edition of stadia like
everything in destiny to shadow keep
smashed in all their so if you want to
play on stadia yeah so there's that and
then the hour-long stream from Bungie
which before we get going I do have to
say I think you can tell the the the the
grip has been lifted a little bit they
were they were free they were they they
talked more candidly in that video
especially mark and Luke in the
beginning never seen them talk like they
were just like
they were just this their whole demeanor
and everything like that was just they
got to say what they wanted to they knew
they know they're not gonna spoil
everything
but they're not hey we can do whatever
we want to hey the Internet yeah it's
all blood like whatever it is they want
like they were able to address
everything and I liked just the tone of
how it started
so yeah the candor the candor just pure
transparency you felt like a release you
felt a freedom you could you sensed it
in the way they were taught they were
they were truly being themselves it and
again I don't want to use you know
scapegoat stuff but there was no
overlords over them they were breeding
them and that is that was refreshing to
see especially the waste thought it was
just like to grow that loved s to be
talking about destiny and say hey let's
get to it
you know so it's good yep so yeah the
leaks were fairly true that got out
there I tried not to get those too much
through my my channels but they were
definitely out there so if you saw them
shadow keep is what comes in the fall
and they're not really batting an eye
it's September 17 so you got border 3 on
the 13th whoa and then destiny on the
17th so yeah yeah they're basically is
saying that's good what's up so we know
what's that was good
I listened whoa all right I was the boy
that nobody call that because I'll be
the first to admit I was running scared
I'd be like you know we move our date
back I'm cool yeah and it was that's
that was a power move man
that's a power that that is confidence
in what you are doing and let's be
honest they would have moved it will we
have been upset like we would understood
the climate we would have understood
yeah yeah but for them to do that like
Wow so we're talking 17th right we talk
September 17th yeah so it's a Tuesday so
we've got like a two-week kind of break
I guess cuz the season pass really goes
through August is what they said and
really if it was August 27th through
like September 2nd or whatever would
have been the last week of the previous
season oh yeah I guess a two-week
which maybe your transitions if you're
doing other things which they talked
about and we're just gonna open this
other can of worms let's go draw save my
xbox playstation pc and the new player
in the game stadia all for like
literally you played on stadia on your
google phone which i've got apples so
they said that might come later but
playing on your google phone sit home at
your computer log up log into steam by
the way wow who swung that you swung for
him and that's funny like they're gonna
be like epic oh you got borderlands you
got those steams like destiny
yeah just dropping the mic on destiny
yeah they did what was it uh the market
our partnership with halo as well so um
steams back in the game fighting strong
you know i'll obviously we do epic goes
out here being very aggressive it has a
lot of money too so don't don't like
they may just be sitting there but they
have a lot of money and they've save it
up to so no question about that that was
powerful that's Bob moving and got stuff
so much don't know I know I was like
there's gonna be tire AIDS and tangent
things like that so if you guys are
listen to this on audio this may be all
over the place and there's one in
advance because it's however long this
man can stay awake but between what
we've got with shadow keep the stopped
about stadia we've got season opulence
cuz the raid launched and thoughts about
how that's going so far the raid race
like we've got a lot of stuff to talk
about today we're kind of going reverse
order of news we're gonna hit with just
what happened and then work back to
seasonal opulence toward the end because
I know you guys want to hear about
shadow keep and all this stuff going on
first so for shadow keyboard you want to
start do you want to do you I'll let you
just take a topic and go because we're
just gonna have to hit all yeah I mean
for me you know shout that Lord attic I
was talking with him and you know it was
basically sequence of events it's it's
the the cross they you know say we got
that and that's what I was focusing on
that first before you a shadow key and
I'm just thinking man berries man like
destiny is the ultimate friend game and
you know just between me and you before
we do in this podcast right like you
know you're on PC I'm on Xbox I got a
dedicated clan you know you made the
move over get you seeing how much better
and
is and I'm just like man and then you
know finally when they went free right
maybe like off it yeah yeah be like
there's no excuse now come on Pinellas
yet God like he's roping me and I'm like
all right all right got to do rig boom
so just to hear that and to think of all
the store shot the gaming for tables on
the podcast with him brat podcast last
night and we were just talking and
what's funny is he literally put this in
the in the in the air cuz we're talking
about it and he's like yo you know well
you know obviously the Stadion news
leaked yes last night and he's like yo
um what if like they gave everyone like
an entry point a free right so you're
like nailed that one day yeah I'm boom
Eddie I'm like bro you on it so um you
know just went snow with a crossed a dog
get ready to share a key which is that
dude you know how to understand how
tremendous this is like this is an
iconic moment for the franchise and no
more berries everyone's playing together
and I could name so many users of best
players of destiny that's like hey I'm
on ps4 hey you know I'm saying I'm PC
hey it's just like we love this game but
kit play together now you reinvigorate
the base you get everybody together
shout to do mental it's overwhelming
when he said I need new pair oh it is
such I was talking to Neil like people
are hitting me is over it was an
emotional thing like y'all we're going
to play together bro like that is insane
I just moved my character so that's
first let's get Chucky okay
Shou keep a flower eros is Boise yeah
they did that reveal in like stadia got
the reveal trailer first would you do
that actually
yeah are you still holding to your Xbox
it does not stop we do that we go down
again huh notice this is white as well
because the reason being is look at the
listen to the mentality right
everything is no barriers right
everywhere if you look on the screen
Xbox was not eliminated clearly so now
this animates hooks
shots Luke Smith and you took some shots
when it came to like exclusive stuff
with exotics they took a lot of
Activision shots in my opinion I thought
you some subliminals out there you know
that's one very very apparent one so yes
so to me all this is so smart like the
stadia thing they're out there and
streaming get it in more devices
straight is not for everybody below
there's gonna be people that utilize
that they don't have a console and don't
have a box that maybe have like but you
have a potato you could run it at 10:06
of other things as well like if I wanted
to go up and lay like hey there's
something going on for the weekend all
all again for destiny if you knew get
stayed and you just get the ultra caster
whatever and I go up and I take my
controller in the Ultra cast up to my
parent my wife's parents house and I go
up there and I'm like hey can I do that
like at least one login is ER or you
know knew what I'm gonna do I don't know
if I can record a video but I could I
could literally just take the cast go
play and be good to go just because I
have that say D access and then come
back home sit on my computer in Budokan
steam like just the flexibility of the
process eight pieces is huge like my
nephews that are always on ps4 they
could literally walk to my brother's
computer sit down and be like hey what's
up guys now I'll play with them I can
help them with content like cuz they
could jump in and be like hey it's like
they both need to whisper the word and
be like right jump in my backpack
I'm gonna take you at the time on their
account and stuff like that like just
the I mean shout-out to follow-up plays
he's one of those that I've wanted to
play with forever he's always on ps4 now
the curiosity will be some that have
consoles and computers and stuff like
that of you go controller keyboard mouse
and that's one of the reasons I do think
cross play - probably the infrastructure
for them is gonna take them time to get
to the cross plane I think that's one of
those pieces that is probably in their
mind it's like we know everybody was
like hey you know what is it I'm trying
to think of what recently Dauntless is
cross play right Call of Duty is that
cross play as well or that's cross
playing and so but those are they have a
lot more money behind them yeah they
have the epics they have the
Activision's they have the money to go
hey this is also a thing bungees like
okay we're at least gonna use our API
played anywhere we're gonna work on the
rest because that's gonna take some time
so I'm this is a huge huge step I think
to get it started yeah I mean you you
nailed it
because I I literally think it's it's
baby steps and I literally think it's
one of those things that also let's be
honest on a balanced perspective you
know we see what's going on like what
other games like if you have you know
PCs out here 16 plus frames and stuff
like that so they're gonna have it
inherent advantage man smiles keyboards
gonna have that hair event so this thing
has to be done right so I still think
that's a little ways away I think it's
coming but I think it's a ways but but
to me cross progression is so much more
important right now in the immediate
like you said you may have to play with
your fam you're gonna be anybody that
you know you couldn't that is just
that's really tremendous you know I'm
saying so that was the first thing off
the bat as far as back to the you know
the stadia thing I think like I said
this is just them expanding spread their
wings getting this thing out on more
devices getting people who've never
played st a chance to get into that
ecosystem hitting that base up right so
that's one - the reason what marks are
again I see is that they're gonna do
their ex-con solution at um III right in
my opinion there's no way that des T is
not part of that I mean again the but
the mentality that I'm seeing from
Bungie is we are not restricting you I
can't see them say yeah I can't see them
saying and unless again which I feel
this is a hard aa really far-fetched you
know some contractual agreement the
studio says only our streaming platform
that I got a C but I doubt it
so that was that what practice a key
wait before you get into that you go
yeah no no no well it was like cross
Navy's huge like I think blatant we
could harp on that for a long time for
stories and things like that and just
cross the million fourth but the one
thing I want to talk about is four cross
save too before we get into actually the
like the needy Gertie of the new stuff
yeah absolutely I want to make like kind
of a separation here and say the the
influx of new people ah from so this is
what I want this is the reason why I
want to go to the sword because I know
you wanna keep no no wait wait wait we
got a lot talk about but destiny to new
light whoa now this this is what but you
just got done saying like hey this is a
thing like we were talking about
yesterday and all the stuff going on so
I don't want to take the take the honor
here I want to let you explain what new
is to everybody listening yeah well they
say the vibe I got from it was just that
you know the problem always inherently
been with destiny is when you try to get
someone on board right and it's like hey
I want to play with you guys that looks
cool
you know forsaken or whatever alright
cool well now you got to get it
you gotta get the base game there you
gotta play the campaign then you gotta
beat this then you gotta be you know
Osiris then you gotta be one month by
the time they're doing all that old
content they're so disinterested to try
to you know I'm saying to get to you oh
yeah that it it becomes a disconnect so
the way it seems new light works is boom
you jump in you start literally d1 is
right at like you're born the Cottagers
mission it seems like yeah yeah and you
just come through and then um you know
you get you get going and at that point
there's no restriction you can go
wherever you want those planets are not
locked out so to speak now I guess the
vibe I'm getting is I guess maybe
endgame content then it's like okay
you're gonna have to commit to that
planet so to speak and invite that
expansion that's the vibe I'm getting
but correct me if I'm wrong what are you
getting from okay so new light is gonna
have everything through destiny to year
one it's getting on all the planets
you're gonna be able to go to and you're
actually gonna be able to go to the moon
to the Dreaming city and the tangled
Shore now be an exotic quest be it last
wish raid be its and certain things that
is gonna take like the Forsaken
expansion that's gonna buy a price for
everything included in forsaken and what
annual pass I think for the annual past
like the free stuff like the free quest
those might still be out there I'm
wondering but I think the Annual Pass
quest anything specifically to that
wouldn't be part of the Forsaken package
right but I still go there and see it
which is interesting yes you for my
understanding activities are not locked
out right no like you got crucible you
got strikes you got gambit that's all
the stuff you can go into gambit brime I
wonder how they're gonna address that
I'm hoping it's just that's open to
right that wasn't specifically asked but
you've got a lot of things that people
can jump in and that's just free and the
level they start at she was basically
saying that's probably I know she said
750 at the level light level you start
out so you're like hey I want to do 750
hey I did my first intermission I know
how to shoot a gun okay where are we
going in shadow keep I'm gonna jump
right in with you
they have the option to jump straight in
with you if they bought shadow keep so
if they get new light they get in there
they've experiment for a little bit big
it's free try it out for a minute
go jump around in some plane and see how
it feels hey this is cool like okay
what's shadow key 35 bucks okay y'all go
play that with you cool okay 35 bucks
I'm already 750 you've got some default
set of whatever and you literally can go
750 jump in with your friends they're
right at the start of shadow keep not
having knew the other stuff now you can
go play the old campaigns warmind
curse of our sires red ward you can go
experience all that stuff you can go to
the Leviathan you can go to the you know
other to raid layers you can do all of
that stuff for free and they said it
sounds like basically what they said is
they don't want you to open a directory
and be like holy crap I have like 12
places I'll go and I mean Atta said
blank 17 he said it perfect it's like
that's too much to be like what the hell
do I do so they're kind of gonna you
might pick a planet or they might say
hey go to the European dead zone hey
you've kind of like you've been here a
little bit now you can go to Titan so
they want you to like kind of see these
places in like and it's free so I mean
you know it's up to you on time mm-hmm
and you can see these places they're
just trying not to be late
here's everything it's like right here's
a little bit of a trip since it's freeze
you can kind of dabble in a couple
places to see what it's like I don't
know if there's a place where if you see
a couple planets you're like hey you
want to start the red war campaign BAM
go like I don't know where they're gonna
have those distinctions it'll be kind of
curious to see absolutely but I just
like the fact you start at 750
everything scales in destiny we know
that anyway so you might feel a little
over level but if you're getting through
the old stuff it's not gonna matter
anyway
but you can just literally go hey do you
like new light cool you hunt jump in a
shadow keep with me cool jump into
shadow keep 750 go and that's it like
that's so easy for like mmm I have a
brother-in-law you know he's thinking
about a computer eventually he's like
dude you were so far into destiny to do
just by shadow keep we'll be good to go
that's all you have to say that so and
that's the other thing like shadow
keeping itself I know I'm saying a lot
and I'll let you go no no you you
educate you move about what bits and
pieces of driving I'm like so I'm Ed
you're educating me on the little
nuances that I missed you know I'm
saying but no keep going keep going
yeah so then playing shadow keep it's
gonna be all occurred things the season
we'll be a la carte unless you just want
to buy them all which you can't have the
option to do it with the collectors but
all those pieces are like all a cart
you're not gonna be stuck like hey you
wait for the view to come out on season
The Drifter which also on them puts
importance for that seasonal content to
be to be hoped for more of what you want
to be like is this up to spec do I buy
this season so if you wait like two days
and be like hey I'm out of town for the
weekend is this thing cool yeah this is
cool you should probably get it for like
eight or ten dollars hey this looks like
do you like gambit not really well you
know just go play God of War this time
of year and then come back to the fall
and you can buy that one like the Owen
Hart nature is cool about those pieces
but just the the onboarding of new light
and then the ala carte nature in the
starting-point of like 750 light is such
a great decision to bring people in on
every platform in cross like if my
playstation is upstairs and I just want
to be like go play upstairs on my TV for
a little I can just go do that too it's
gonna feel weird with a controller
because it's not mouse and keyboard but
that's but I can still just go up and be
like I haven't looked at this in u2 on a
TV in a while that's no good like I do
just can do that late yeah that's really
really the cross save and then the the
free onboarding I I mean these are
things that were rumored and leaks and
stuff like that but man when it's all
official and finally set out there by
them and the way they said everything
yeah the messaging was perfect I think
that um again this is so monumental for
the franchise it's just funny about this
game and I just gotta go off a little
tangent in the sense that it's like I've
never seen a game like this he I mean
I've been game a long pretty old I
describe more iron Lord I've been around
the block a while and I've never seen a
game go through let's be a destiny has
been at the forefront of a lot of
pinnacle moments we've learned about
console exclusivity you learning about
cross play you know that we could have
crossed could be across across seas and
I'm saying now you know we're taking
some key words I'm hearing MMO for the
first uh you know sit I love that Dan
was like I don't think you've ever said
that needs like maybe not
like they literally they're doing so
many things and it's just it's
interesting to see the job cuz um as a
fan of the game and you know we've
suffered for being you know support of
this game when we started this podcast
right you know look at casting like
curse of Osiris and people like
seriously crazy be like yeah it's so I'm
sure yeah we're doing it okay yep roll
with that it's just a crazy journey and
it's just it's cool to see the evolution
it's cool to see them unshackle that's
cool too I'm just excited about possibly
you can put it this way I'm excited this
is the first I'm not even really caring
I'll be we're gonna get to the content
we gonna get to shadow keep I am so
excited about the possibilities of all
those things you just mentioned you know
there and in terms of bringing
communities get do you know what that's
gonna do to this online community yeah
you know what's gonna do it is base what
everyone rockin together at least
interacting together and picking where
they want to go and how they want to
consume the content like this is a game
changer this is the direction the
industry is going and I'm glad destiny
is one of the first like you know when
at one of the first console MMO try to
really kind of push this thing for this
is exciting really exciting yeah so
there's just a lot there's so many late
there's so many examples where this is a
good thing and you probably could never
list them all but I think new light
basically the best way I can and I'm
gonna click on this I can kind of
describe talk about it somewhat
intelligently on their page basically
they say play for free start September
17 the same day as Cherokee dive right
under the world of destiny to experience
a responsive first-person shooter combat
to explore rich worlds with sweeping
vistas stunning visuals to earn the
arsenal of powerful weapons and armor
bring your personal is guarding into a
large large variety of activities and
modes from cooperative quests
competitive modes challenging in-game
activities and more the fact that
somebody can go be like hey I've never
experienced a rape you can go do it for
free you can raid for free like is that
that that's crazy in and of itself like
you knew Leviathan you can do Argos you
can do spire which probably taken
- the first - not the last one no it's
free rate is huge like they've never
known that man do you like nothing it
will go try this thing for free for free
you get free is undefeated you know
listen that's how you get a man again
that's hot list once you said that our
solar system the PC I remember boom it's
free
oh ok we're down low wait wait wait
where do I get this yeah
is it listen I'm looking at my timeline
shut the map piscatella NPD oh good guy
had him in I'm on a podcast many time
and he's not the biggest fan of destiny
let's just see it yeah and yesterday I
seemed at risk until her putting a tweak
in the house installing 70 he's like out
of his mind he doesn't even know what
he's doing except he does again because
free is undefeated there's no barrier
there's no like the all the reasons that
people that have gone away from death do
they just come back and they just keep
charging me you know bro you ain't got
to do it now you know what they say they
would have but attic I would tell me
like who knew like I do like the brick
room we're cool you could sit down this
season still rock out with us with
everything else pick up drift if because
he's a gamma guy you know who can pick
you can pick what you want it's like
going to like a buffet like yo you know
what the shrimp we got to meet over they
will get the steak over here like yeah
you're like hey like Borderlands 3 dude
come out and like say March and there's
this new season I don't know if I want
to pick it up right now
I'm scared I'm just gonna go play bored
in so we'll come back in next season
it's cool like there's no the freedom is
there is nice now I know somebody was
saying it's like free to play doesn't
pay the bills what they're giving you
for free has already been out for two
years up like so long at this point
they're not losing you thing they're
just trying to get more people into the
game into the newer content following
the season passes spending money and
ever vers stuff like that they want to
do and you know cosmetics and expansions
are how they're gonna continue to
support this game so it seems really
cool and you know what I want to expound
on that point which is about how they
gonna support it let's
honest now that we rockin opulence your
much father I literally barely turned it
on like this morning and um I just saw
the other first door right and I'm
looking at ok direct purchase this is
the cosmetic of the week I'm like ok
this it's almost like a little mall now
right this is the way they're going for
monetization and I personally don't have
a problem with it because to be honest
like I didn't like where you know the
practice some things are bright there's
some now you can almost directly
purchase what you want and I think
that's gonna be another revenue source
you know I'm saying and here's the thing
for people that don't understand like oh
how they're gonna support themselves the
reason why games like fortnight and all
these free-to-play are thriving first of
all if you have engagement you have you
give them you you lower the barrier of
entry and you get more people a more of
your friends playing guess what they
gonna tend to spend more money living in
your game buying cosmetics they gon tend
to spend more money buying an expansion
or whatever it is that's how you sustain
it the key with this next generation
people understand is going to be
engagement and gate and for a game like
destiny which is the ultimate friend
game the ultimate play with everybody
this is how you do I think they're
really on to something I love the
direction that they go yeah I don't know
if we can probably talk too much more
about that I mean yeah it's like it's
everything through your one force Akins
gonna be its own piece I don't know at
some point if that may be free after
some time if that may get discounted in
sales we know how steam sales go just
wait for one of those all those pieces
will be there so and honestly if you're
like worried about or wondering on
things and you jump in a shadow keep and
be like cool but I don't have what if I
don't have forsaken I don't know maybe
wait for it to go on sale add that to
your Steam library and then or whatever
you gotta do so it'll be interesting to
see how all this stuff works and kind of
yeah have a system together like you
know it's like ok so if you go to
forsaken is gonna say you need the
Forsaken package to play this you know
dungeon or mission or whatever like I'll
be kind of curious where the lines are
drawn yes
specifically like forsaken kind of
wandering yes absolutely absolutely yeah
so we've got cross save huge guys a new
free entry in new light and it sounded
now bike speculation you can call me if
you think I'm out of the box here they
said hey it seasons go like ok so say
shadow keeps gonna be 800 and then or
whatever it's gonna be I don't know I'll
say then they keep bumping it as the
seasons go then say like season what if
its season 9 is like eight fifty say if
you buy shadow keep in January when
you're in that new season or however you
would start that level when you jump in
do you think you jump in at like eight
hundred like fifty below the question so
let's say you keep matching as the
expansions keep coming out to stay fresh
like hey I want to come in and join cuz
it sounded like like if you jump in you
buy shadow keep later
you wouldn't what do you level you gonna
jump in on there like well that might
count for one season of content so I'm
wondering how that power match is gonna
go cuz they keep doing the power surge
and I'm for us when you jump in is it
just kind of like you're good to go or
mmm that'll be kind of yeah that's the
question I guess my theory is probably
maybe they keep power surge on some
level and then you know you will be
slightly over leveled for the older
content now being if they stay
consistent to how they wanted a pair
again this is new territory now that
should be very clear like this is sub
they're talking a whole bunch of stuff
that they've never really done so I'm
gonna go with that for right now cuz
they seem to be power surge seems to be
the route that they like right now that
I think they really like this new
experiment of new people just jumping in
your Robby soon as opulence start at
home it's like quest here boom your 690
if you and you know you haven't played
so I think they made go that right
that's just my guest oh yeah it's like
it seems like when okay about see how
you doing okay bad see what's over
brother so yeah just like it watch I
want to just walk around and shake like
everyone in that Studios hand like Luke
and Noseworthy and Eric Osborne like the
big three guys like and everybody from
the top down everybody in the background
and shout out on stream somebody and
switch pointed out and I didn't notice
it for the longest time whoever faces
that
like recording area with that Oh with
the monitor with their two dogs on it ha
ha ha your dogs are cemented out there
for life because they're like giant it's
like half the monitors one dogs faces a
half the monitors the other dogs face I
was diving with somebody pointed because
I couldn't stop looking at him they're
like big fluffy or dogs just looked
hilarious but shout out to everybody in
that studio and it's like sometimes
you'd be like hey and like and you could
hear it's like it seems like the way
that studio is built they're almost like
on an upper tier for that leg switch
area and like the entire floor down
there's like cheering and hollering from
back there is like I'm just like I don't
think I don't know if any of them have
ever listened to one episode of this so
I have no idea but if they do somebody
pass the word along to everybody in that
entire studio because like man there's
so many so many hard-working people in
there and I just want to thank them for
bringing it's for sticking with this
this long and being able to like get to
this point right here or at with this
cross save with cross play like working
their butt off having having the ability
to like sever ties and be your own
studio and that's one of the guys if I
doc said it perfectly it's like it's
it's exciting and terrifying at the same
time in a he said it perfectly because
it's like they're on their own so they
have to make the right calls but now
they have the free pool their choices
are there so I gotta say something so
can we put to rest finally as a studio
they're capable of doing a DLC like
shadow keep without have it or not work
free can I get a bit back down damn it
cuz this Alexis it's you cotton they
look like they've been working hard and
they were able to put aside their d3
dreams and give us this great content
and keep us in the news cycle and keep
everybody except do you see what I do
okay there's one caveat to that can I
say one cannot tonight no no how's PDP
been for the last year they even
mentioned that in the stream page no
that's that they mentioned they're like
hey we've our folk but it's like if we
focus on PvP if we focus on strikes we
can't deliver this new content that was
said so again they are there's a point
where resources are yes believe me I'm
happy it's coming not arguing that
you're never gonna argue that like
that's one of those I will usually make
like little stupid meddling net that if
I lose it I'm gonna be happy anyway so I
don't have much to lose like oh no I
have to buy you drink I get content in
September god forbid
like I was like I don't care but in all
seriousness that's a point to where they
still want to keep that as a non like
you know like right before shadow key
comes out yeah there's probably gonna be
some overtime but like generally they
want to keep that as a well balanced
work-life balance have some like alone
time and they want to keep that as a
good as a as a studio that other studios
look up to
it's a studio that you want to work at
and that's the balance of lake hey we're
not gonna pump out you know fortnight
seasons of content all the time and
killer developers it's like and they're
not gonna do that and that's the point
to where the people that have been
waiting for the pvp stuff have been
there like thank you for being patient
now we're trying to figure out that
balance so hey you let up you love their
transparency yes absolutely
yeah all I'm saying is as a games as a
service and especially now with the
free-to-play you know um with this model
you can't go away that's all I was
trying to say you cannot go away you go
away you're forgotten and the thing is
they don't you forget destiny you will
not forget that destiny has been a too
big of a thing for too long even if it's
like even if what I had said had
happened you're not gonna you're not
gonna forget about destiny II we
represent the hardcore but I understand
that we do not come now here's the thing
for look at the casuals look at the map
Chris could tell look at the people who
do not care about destiny and look at
your Twitter feed and see what they're
doing where that's because they love it
when you give them great content you get
them these announcements you keep them
now people like oh my god the future
looks so bright like that's what you
want read this it's free-to-play its
games and service this is the new wave
and guest needs to pioneer and just good
to see it's good to see so yeah I will
say my damn I told you so
good god yeah what a torture
two different people saying except like
neo saying people are starting to forget
and Christian killin Klingberg sorry you
won't bring back casuals with expansions
and that's the look that I guess that's
my role let me get Christian let me get
Christian right away before you say
anything alright me say mine okay I'm
ready
what is like what is gonna bring back
people you see baldur's gate gets
announced with like a boulders gate 3
you see like a Mass Effect 4 big
iterations and numbers are still the
thing they're gonna be something in
somebody's the mind to be like this is a
point where I can come back and get
fresh now you can go in and explain all
this to them of how this new stuff is
gonna work and all those other pieces
but iterations and numbers are still
gonna be one of those things that had
one of the biggest influxes no matter
how good all of this was they need us
freaking phenomenal um yeah I was like
I'm curbing my language right I was
gonna stop but it's amazing but in but
still you and this is probably the best
way they could probably bring people in
but people are still like hey is that
still destiny to know if it was destiny
3 it still opens a different door in
people's minds now you and I can sit
there like explain it to them they can
see videos they'll see your reviews
coming out hey this is cool you can get
in for free but if somebody was just
like destiny 3 comes out with
PlayStation 5 that's still gonna oh
that's still gonna peak an interest in
more people's minds is all I'm getting
it now is a live service like you don't
want it to die and that's why we're like
Annual Pass what is it gonna be small
expansion now I don't think shadow keeps
is gonna be as facing all bro this will
force it up to me this is not forsaken
this is looking warmind ish at least
this is not small this is not this just
thing it's not for sinking but it's big
this is rise of iron yeah this is
reservoir and this you anything don't
get crass that was dados most important
question nandi's like what about d3 so
if you always do a live service that's a
different animal if they wanted to go
for a d3 it would have been a different
thing you like and that's kind of the
wandering of
like how how long is d2 gonna be is it
gonna be d2 are they just gonna start
slapping names on destiny 2 for
September stuff but then here's the
question is like how much content do you
get with a d3 mm dude like and that and
that's that's not an easy thing for them
to develop I know but also and this is
way for them to keep adding here and
adding here when you want your influx of
like eight strikes and eight new pvp
maps and four new planets that gigantic
size of content that doesn't come until
there's an iteration the way they
explained it and you could tell that's
what Luke is holding on to right where
and that's what he's out in the
background of like and that's a nice day
it's like that's enough this is their
current plan to support what they've got
they haven't a year of content playing -
I need to say something I mean II say so
alright here's dick now he's saying like
you know the casuals won't come back and
what with expansions here's the thing
that picked a niche he doesn't listen
again if you would have I'll be I'm
gonna be brutally honest if they would
not have had shadow people right let's
say shadow keep was not announced as no
errors trailers none of that yeah and
they would have said still cross play
all these different form and crock keep
saying cross by cross say hey all these
different formats you know I'm saying
streaming this that that is tremendous
that is tremendous that is a barrier so
that's what I'm trying to say Christian
and I'm not trying coming sure is I've
seen this comment before it's just that
you know people have to understand like
once you remove barrier and she look at
a game like fortnight right
once you remove barrier of entry or
demand then you throw a by the way free
399 let's go that it that changes the
whole scope of your game now now it's
something else so now there's no excuse
for anyone to say well I don't know
because no it's free here you go check
it out
check it out you don't like it alright
cool I'm saying but now you check out
and that's again you bring more people
in that I cannot understate how like I
am still on cloud and I know for that
and we wick this stuff I want to talk
about shadow keep right now that what I
saw and I'm glad I waited to start this
who
there was there was two parts of shadow
keep that I'm like and there's one part
that I know you had to be doing like a
back flip and I can't wait to hear your
thoughts on Ornette you knows it's
already coming for you Oh dad dust off
mom a little faded or exert you know
thinking yeah I keep a half but yeah man
we got to get into Yankee alright so
either way we know what's gonna happen
for now speculation for the future will
happen as we of course keep playing the
game but yeah destiny to shadow keep
this is a thing true so first we got the
trailer mmm heiress is back in the one
place she doesn't want to be by the way
we're aware of all places does she not
want to go back where she almost died
yeah and she is literally back there she
talks about facing her nightmares and in
this little brief trailer and there's a
couple other snippets that we see we see
hive with like an electric field around
the ogres goes okay who is prison of
elders scorch cannon boss oh um yeah
home it's Hanks no that's tannic that's
from the strike that sort of strike so
it's mean I can't remember who I'm
talking to somebody in chat help us
right now one got one of the prison of
elders bosses one of the prison of
elders like skulls goal ass yeah like he
was in there yeah bro
it looked like he was in there it looks
like he was standing next to two other
guys as it rotated over they looked even
weirder and I haven't seen before you
had a girl walking in you had like crazy
big night captains thank you chat
they're getting there crota Lance's
crota's phantasm but he's walking around
in like a I don't know they mentioned
the dark below like going back to oh
it's your least favorite raid are you so
happy to go back there now I'll deal
listen out of the love in the UK I'm
excited I got I Bend Anita Yuen out I I
definitely have excited to see I didn't
think I would miss the mood to be on one
quick thing to be honest when I when the
leak came out right and we saw the
graphic you just saw the planning and
you see mood
hey I gonna live but I was my first
reaction raw reaction right seeing this
all right then he got Aris Russell feels
back I'm like okay you know she's crazy
she's back we gotta see what's going on
then I got the vibes I got was you know
her fallen rating you seem like the the
necklaces or whatever some memorabilia
her fallen teen you know I want to see
what's going on there they expanded on
how more of a you know expanded it is
then what we remember it is and then I
think the key is I got a shout out my
boy addict on this one thing he always
said that he would [ __ ] a dream that's
why when he's texting I'm in the barber
shop she's like oh my god oh but he
never says that like he's the most
negative Nancy you could show him
anything I don't know he's gonna god I'm
like what oh my god did you watch it I'm
about to watch it now the whole bosses
in the atheon it it I'm like are you
serious and he's like oh my God he's
going he just wanted that like so it
almost feels like people could say we
use an asset whatever they want
am I your pain has a destiny fan these
are iconic encounters that we have from
d1 and that these guys are not finished
for whatever reason whatever's going on
in the moon they are not done so I'm
dying to know the law behind it what's
happening and then the question I have
for you is do you think you got to talk
a little law now do you do you do you
think that the raid team is good fight
who didn't our original R a team that
got like tormented killed and we have
oh the other 5 Guardians yeah what you
think you I don't know too much do you
think they finished finished I don't
think that qualifies in bungees mind as
a boss okay okay now what I would like
to see and that's what some people have
been speculating on if all bosses
weren't giant things if there were
smaller targets or more like different
things and stuff like that like I would
like to see something like that or maybe
one of the encounters before like hey if
there's this crazy thing controlling
quote nightmares which is what most of
this stuff seems to be and this is like
she's like I see it in my nightmares all
of this stuff is what she's potentially
talking about down in you know the dark
below basically all of this it seems
like all of these things are brought
back in some way now do you have to
cross plains to go face your nightmares
are we fighting like they said phantasm
late I mean a phantasm I could probably
Google the day I'm definition and see
something interesting here cuz that was
that area simulation chat say stuff lost
in the moon predates Eris and her team
yeah this is interesting man Golden Age
while he says uh so this is why the part
and this is why I got to go do it like
literally break down on the later two I
might do that which as well a phantasm
because it said crota phantasm a figment
of the imagination an illusion or an
apparition an illusionary likeness of
something so in something to wear when
she's talking about nightmares it is
truly fighting something you but there's
something also dude like what are these
like ogres that have this like
electricity this way it's like field
that is around them if you guys are
listening to this on audio sorry the
videos got some stuff going on so check
out the YouTube channels but it
definitely yeah they're also saying
black-winged we'll get to that in a
minute put a pin in that mm-hmm yes yes
it's gonna say pin and there we go get
here we gonna get there and that's the
point to where this is this is heiress
story and that's what they said in the
vite the as they were talking to do in
the interviews they're like hey this is
the you know The Drifter story this is
season of opulence this is doing stuff
with Callas this is gonna be air story
what she faced what
you run through I don't think it's gonna
go back I think we're gonna go to what
has happened at the moon is something's
overtaking it even more now but yeah
it's definitely gonna be they said okay
size wise as this is this is the most
unorganized podcast by the way sorry
yeah yeah we all so much news man when I
was just just trying to remember
everything just off one viewing mmm
twice as big as the moon was before yes
I did hear that yes that's a new
destination mmm
so that will be substantial because
there was Hellmouth mm-hmm
I don't remember the name of the other
two places but there were three so if
you have six zones
it's bigger than tangled Shore yes but
tangled row and dreaming city together I
still think will be bigger yeah I think
so but sighs if you have legs that's
like if you have three originals maybe
three two or three new zones something
like that but twice as big that should
be really cool but yeah what we're
facing I don't I don't know what is in
this view if this is just like because
they just have these little things
marching up in little like rotating
caramel pictures there's not a lot of
point of references right so like the
activities were the only thing we really
see is like kind of the red keep
structure and crota like that's the one
we all see and Kurt is like looking big
and ginormous and everything else and
he'll like what exactly it is that the
play seems to be everything the your
guardians worst fears all their
nightmares kind of that's the play that
it's either and when I heard them I saw
Gul I'm seeing you know I'm saying like
the ancient Oryx assault Castle like
yeah man this is really cool concept and
yeah like I said shop attic I mean he's
always told me such like it would be
cool if they had something way you face
these iconic bosses he's always he's a
boss guy and and yeah he's gonna get his
dream with this one man this this looks
like we're really really doing it yeah
so just to give a reading on the bunging
page for shadow keep itself it says a
new chapter as the heroes of the last
safe city turned their attention to the
frontiers beyond the protection of the
new vein of the vanguard new
nightmares have emerged nightmares and
capitalized by the way have emerged from
the shadows of our long-forgotten moon
called forth by the haunting visions
from her tormented past Eris morn has
returned and Unleashed something that
once slumbered beneath the lunar surface
a long dormant power even she cannot
control and they actually describe that
as she let something loose she did
everything she broken some she is she no
no she tripped over the lock I don't
like I mean however you want to read or
phrase that it says return to the moon
during deep into a mysterious enemy
Citadel help Eris slay these nightmares
before they reach out beyond the moon
and to cast humanity back into an age of
darkness and that's the one piece I
wanted to hold on to is yes the darkness
is closer than we think yes and that was
stated at some point in there now this
is talking about the nightmares and
darkness so I don't even I don't think
this is gonna be the triangle ships or
the veil or anything like that I wrote
and that's why I still think there is a
d3 somewhere yeah absolutely absolutely
but they still stick into that formula
of once we ended we beat Gaul and we
sought a cinematic of the travelers
light going to each planet that's the
sequence they've been true true to that
for the Morlock but yeah the darkness
below dark below like and what if
they're truly just gonna call the raid
like the darkness below or so like go
back an old raid name or something like
that but yeah that Vidak I'm gonna have
to break down specifically we can't
really watch it on the stream but
there's so what did what what are your
takeaways for like act like do you think
there's gonna be a new activity do you
think there's like business and other
escalation protocol is this gonna be
your next wave based activity it's a
possibility I mean generally with new
new expansion new content they've always
debuted a new activity so I definitely
think we're getting something and maybe
that is along the lines that whole force
thing that's a possibility and it'll be
cool they could say that for array but I
doubt it they probably might want to
introduce some new power there um yeah I
mean they're definitely gonna go that
route I feel as far as um new activity
mentions that there's some key points
you
also mentioned they said about the moon
also there's gonna it's not there's like
central characters obviously with Arison
and this whole thing yeah this is also
coming back yeah and I don't yeah I'm
trying like who would that be
who would that be and Bob was talking
about Mario mm-hmm they said yeah cuz
dad oppressed him he pressed him about
Maura and heiresses relationship he
pressed them about Aldrin very impressed
with that press I still think we get
nodren I think they just holding on I
didn't want to say that's gonna tie in
tomorrow later though I think yeah I
think those who are yeah but the vibe
I'm getting there's still some stories
during this expansion that they are
going to give us nuggets and pieces as
far as expansion of those those
storylines because our yeah that'll add
some really really good questions yeah
so I mean it's it seems very much
focused on Aris on the moon and that
story piece we've got a new planet twice
the size of the Moon was before which is
nice so they've definitely revamped
rebuilt they're probably using some
areas that were there but they're gonna
be restructured they said it's like your
dreadin has will be different as the
cracks in the surface or change things
up so things seem reformulated I saw a
few little shots that look like old
areas though as well so there they do
seem to be some places you'll recognize
if you play but people who jumped on
like d2 was free hey I've never played
d1 before but d2 is pretty cool I'll
play that what's d1 like some people
have never seen the moon yeah so that
was why when some people when he pressed
him he's like oh this is reusing new
content and this is their true really
first time to what how would they bring
an old planet back how would you bring
back Venus how would you bring back
other places and there's their first
foray into that mmm so absolutely giving
it a reason for a story a lot of people
seem to mention the moon even somebody
would say before like the moon was their
favorite planet mentioned the other day
and we're going back there so a lot of
people enjoy like even just the contrast
of that it's like you got the grays and
you go underneath and you have the
hyvent infrastructure you have phogoth
the giant ogre with all the chains all
over him like all those pieces are out
there seem really really cool now one
other I was like there are multiple
things so give me one
about that whole video you watched about
shadow key that excites you about now
the expansion will go one won't bounce
back and forth give me one thing
and then we'll talk about I don't want
to steal your thunder because this is
one that I just like oh you can say it
now hold my eye you know what my you
know my fire there's actually two but
one definitely tops everything for me so
for one that I saw when I saw armor and
I saw basically we're talking about mods
and configuring unlocking perks and
taking those and putting it on so that
screams transmog basically that almost
sounds like not transmog what it sounds
like
like transmog is taking like I'm wearing
a set of armor but I'm just going to
like put in these little artistic
cosmetic slots this is what I want to
look like this actually looks like I got
a piece of armor I can put whatever
perks I want it which almost yeah more
customization but if it's unlocked and
seen those perks before like hey I
finally got a piece of armor with
enhanced bummer yeah I can go put that
on whatever I want if I want and see
that's the thing cuz destinies it's the
fashion game man and you want to look
flat and I hate right now and I'm
playing off of it and I've got to wear
crap because I just I look homeless
right now man I am straight-up homeless
homeless warlock right now with my robe
of tattered cloth and browns and I look
awful shackleshot gunshot a shout-out to
her by the way she's got a lot to do oh
my god I think it was fall it was like
please make sure you eat take breaths
cuz like the amount of stuff that she's
got a cover and he's like please if you
get cramps in your hands stretch it and
you know sleep little bit stuff like
that laughing cuz she she does a really
really amazing job actually if you guys
haven't followed her before please do it
shackle shotgun if you just look up
something like that you'll find her she
does a recap of like reddit of Twitter
of everything really condenses the Queen
yes I've seen so she does a great thing
today her mind probably exploded
so there's way too much to type so she's
definitely gonna be working hard like
she tweeted something I'd be like I look
terrible like I look homeless I tweeted
back and I was like dude I look homeless
right now so and that's the point to
where if like if I'm getting this other
stuff but I'm like I'm unlocking new
perks and mods and other things like
that like yeah she's got her work to do
but oh my god like I would love to not
work homeless right now
that is HUGE man it's really is it yeah
and what if you ever wonder why
cognitive hazard where enhancement this
is why because I am stubborn I am not
putting on the bum again and I know I
should I know I'm supposed to I know so
to be efficient like how you're being
efficient right oh and fifty finest the
matter we've by the way Oh clearly for a
rainy day I know has a point you're
right but oh yeah it's just one of those
things that that that that really is
needed so that definitely and I'm just
gonna go back to the core element when
I'm hearing we are going back to our PG
level of mechanics oh you're so mean oh
yeah oh sorry
yes we're going to mm oh we're like
we're taking it back to like we still
did he see key points that Luke Smith
said like we don't like the way the
character set up what the abilities is
or what have you and we want to give
more choice more algae because that was
the knock on D - right but D to drop
people like yo why you forcing me to be
in these little pockets with no
customization with all innocent within
the subclass right and that is what I
miss from d1 when you had d1 and you had
all these ability tree and you picked
and you choose right which one and how
you want to configure okay I want to use
that I don't want to use this cool and
it just gave you so much control over
you and it felt like yours and that to
me yeah those are still here in my
stream from when I was watching it live
before
literally arms went up over my head as
soon as they were saying like we want to
we want to it's like mmm oh and they're
like we've always been afraid to say
that he's like we want to get more into
the RPG we want depth and character and
my hands shot up and I was just like
thank you thank you no thank you thank
you that was that's exactly what I've
been asking for for a long time now
actually I preached the day and that's
why we they want the depth in your
character and to me that's one of those
pieces that is so lacking in this game
you look at the armor and what do you
get you get scavenger and reserve perks
like who gives them like I'll bleep
myself there but there is a damn like
something that stuff after a while it's
like that's why I have lots when my
vault is an issue because the only thing
I actually can customize is what I'm
gonna work with what weapons I have well
yes like I was like what if there are
more customizations than the armor what
if my build is a little better what my
super can charge a little faster but
what if I could get rid of a melee and
hold two different types of grenades
like what of all any of that kind I'm
not saying any of that's happening but
like have more choice and depth in your
character and they said these monster
killing machines are gonna have
customization to them now and that is I
lost night I was probably needed new
pants actually yeah rode out that hit
hard and III didn't you just you just
feel the shackles coming up
you know zeg you just feel like yo we're
doing what you guys want and again the
theme seems to be no restrictions no
barriers there's this new Bungie now and
it's exciting like I said like to be
honest again i'ma say it again it's
gonna sound file cuz the era's content
look dope everything like though I am so
hype about the features and what's
happening to the core gameplay more than
I am about the story cat normally it's
always the opposite like oh man did you
see oh my god there's the fort to
treatment city and this happened in it
and that's cool alright we'll get to
that black ring oh my god I'm out fell
out of my chair I forgot about dad we
got to say that now honestly because
everybody is like what are you talking
finishing a nation literally mortal
combat finish it I'm like literally so
the hunter does like a kind of a 360
spin stat
the title literally just does a giant
haymaker and I don't know what the
warlock looks like just a force punch
but before I'm like ogre ogre by the way
no larger than you is flipping away
backwards off the screen
I lost I laughed so hard at that oh my
god what I don't even know like you
can't do that to a month obviously
clearly but like what if you had like an
ogre coming at you and there's a bunch
of stuff behind him and you finish him
and he rolls over the guys like like
whole bunch in a truck and he hits the
16 things behind I'm like word yeah the
Titan Superman punch yeah seriously like
mm-hmm
that makes me so hard and that is almost
like one of the little things of like
what is the unexpected things what would
people like in a d3 d3 would have your
subclasses and stuff like that what
something unexpected you would never
think about coming into destiny beause
that was one I never thought that's just
a weapon type though this is a finishing
like a ultimate melee like it was the
mechanics you vibe I got from the
mechanics just seemed like like you
could have lied to me and said d3 like
this is the three kind of stuff that I
didn't think we were gonna get now right
like this is stuff that I'm like okay
that's definitely down the pipe and you
can see the vibe is there are evolving
this game to what they truly meant it to
be and yeah to have it this early like
yo again I'm more excited about all
these core gameplay mechanic changes
that I have anything else like I'm super
pumped for all this stuff yes there's
there's a a weapon chart or something
I'm gonna have to literally freeze frame
and pick apart or he's saying as you
work through the tears of something to
like unlock it's like when you get to
this level of tears there's like five
columns of these things and he said the
fifth one these are almost gonna be like
exotic tears and that's gonna be really
excited I'm like I don't know like I
don't know if it's like scopes and perks
and stuff that you can unlock if there's
AI I really have to go back and watch
that part because that right there has
me so intrigued
- picking perks are unlocking these
things or how do you build your armor
and there was like a scale of like and
it said like seven of I don't even know
I I have to go back and freeze-frame
that so I know I sound stupid right now
so if you're listening to this I'm gonna
try and post the audio up as soon as
possible so don't sound quite so stupid
mm-hmm oh my god we're getting there in
a single action that was the thing
actually I think I might be talking
about they're bringing back artifacts I
I missed that that was the entire thing
I can't go over it right now mm-hmm
they are it's like that might have been
the thing that was like really
customizable working working for perks
and leveling the thing up you let me let
me spend time with the gear that I want
let me level up this set let me let me
if I spin and get thirty thousand kills
with my go figure that there's actually
a benefit to using a weapon for a while
let me have a customized skill tree
again like those are the things I want
back in this game and if they like
they're saying like you might not have
subclasses now but if you can pick like
you know hammers and six shot golden gun
or a three shot Golden Gun and then six
like a bunch of little perk trees let
you pick your super you pick your perks
like almost go back to a d1 stop and
dude I will be happy yeah like I'm
little nervous though with artifact I'll
be honest when you're not at you saying
I'm like cuz you know it you know I
remember the days of this quarry and you
know I just want to see how far they go
and that they may not be too
game-breaking but it's exciting I'm not
gonna say like I'm anti artifact I just
want to see how far they know what they
do with it yeah yeah it's another slot
for sure but if it has mechanics to it
it'll be interesting
there there are some freeze frames I
need to go back through because I
recorded the whole thing it's like I
wanna scroll back through slowly
Vagabond Oh always good to have you in
here have a little brother yeah yeah the
heavy but yeah she's working the helmet
like though test environment that they
get to work in in this viaduct I love
how they showed that a little bit and
they were talking about
she's like I'm working on a heavy bow
with kind of a knock-back feature let's
see how much this is and you see all the
enemies like explode around like
a little grenade went off and they went
flying around and I was like oh my god I
would have too much fun in that like oh
man can you imagine just being like okay
you build me the model I just need a bow
that functions okay so when I hire this
bow it's got this speed when it hits the
ground it pushes everything away or say
there's a bow that shoots the ground and
then a wave goes for it like the amount
of stuff that I'm sure they can toy
around and try with if they have to have
some crazy stuff and then somebody's got
to be like all right so I made this
thing and you give it to sandbox and be
like hey can you bounce this mat all
right did you see that hand with the
skull like a single shot sniper hand
camera oh that looks cool so we so
here's the one thing oh let's go no late
those things sound really cool but they
I hopefully some time and I know they've
been focused on the annual pass and
other seasons what's up but you get old
exotics that suck if we're still in
destiny - they need love like there's a
lot of out there I mean you got your
astrocyte verse that helps with blinking
I'm going like they brought that it like
how do you like there's only so many
things like guess you can do to a point
but I'm like really yeah I mean it
shoutout to reddit crucible playbook I
did my research on it and at first when
I read The Perks the new perks I was in
the world it's like really ever do that
but I will which is basically for those
who don't know blink is extended but
they added a second part so babe so
basically it's baby Ophidian aspects
right post link so when you post blink
you're handling and all that stuff
reaction is super fast so you get kind
of the drop kind of thing so it's really
a PvP kind of exclusive kind of exotic
that's the vibe I'm getting from it and
I've been hearing positive things you
know any challenge these guys but it you
know but yeah I trust me I'm with you
know like overall i'm you know i want
substantial improvement to underused
exile a lot of these exotics look really
cool i showed up to the design team
right like like and he gave us words
like the slide thing it's like it's cool
in theory but it's literally
like a montage thing mm-hmm like I mean
what if there was like I mean either
they I don't know if I had to sit there
and break down to be like I swear I
could do a video series and be like hey
what can I do with this thing and like
actually think about each one or
something like that and how you can make
some of those better and I'm not a
designer to know what could couldn't
work or what's balance than what isn't
but there's a point where it's like we
went back to this before when we started
this podcast and they were like hey they
want exotics to be exotic and some of
them are really not right they don't
feel ya worthwhile there's I mean Jade
rabbit would she I mean yeah it's a
decent scout rifle if that's what you're
good at but Scouts Dean some love
there's sidearms have a whole huge
problem going on with them being an even
sub played so those are some of the
things to that I want to make sure don't
keep being forgotten it's like I know we
keep getting new stuff but it's like I
want to bring back and be like I do
still want like mmm
I want choice there still I know there's
gonna be a meta I understand that is
always going to happen but I would like
sometimes to be like hey skull of Dyer
ahankara I understand you're awesome is
there something else that I could use
that might lead to a different play
style okay it needs to be play style
differences I understand there's gonna
be meta but if like I go into a crucible
of match and so I was like what is it
how does he like and it's just a
completely different play style than
something else
that would be nice like I know there's
always gonna be like havior and comp
like 4500 drink you're probably gonna be
using a very small subset of items so so
you aren't going to beat the best like
sufficiency top points all those things
are gonna be there but in the point of
quick play and pde and strikes and
things like that if there's a point
where it's like hey there's a void
modifier on okay what if I don't use
skull of diorama car is there anything
that pulls me away from that there
should I just completely completely miss
now let me ask you a question being at
you you going on that
so then how what was your reaction when
Dad oppressed them on meta and sandbox
cadence and the vibe was we're still
sticking with once a season
what was your face day it was probably
what you would expect is just gonna
blog about you to freeze raid out what
yeah
the they explained the P they are very
data-driven we know they are they're
hugely hugely data-driven on many other
decisions they make then they get into
the sesang then they roll it out now
they're gonna have four platforms so
they're gonna have all those pieces that
have to function and as he said it's
like hey you want to tweak a scout rifle
how does a function and gambit in
crucible and PvE and strikes versus the
raid like they if they tweak a scout
rifle and it's like hey we're gonna have
Scout rifles of 30% buff now everybody
just shoots a scout rifle into ribbons
mouth like there are points where they
have M'Baye like okay or we take into
pvp and I'm like to shotting people in
the head halfway across the map and
gambits I'm invading with scout rifles
now Scout rifles in the new meta now
that would be nice if stuff like that
would happened and there would be
there's they have to find that balance
of data-driven decisions mm-hmm but as
they are free now occasionally it would
be really nice to see things like trace
rifle crucible fun like Prometheus wins
like break stuff occasionally just to
see it be like hey and now they did say
for PvP crucible I'm coming to their
defense state yeah and they did mention
I will because you know how I feel I
feel like the red stepchild I'm pvp
lover here I mean not that you're not
but you know I live more in PvP like
literally when I went on reset day when
I watch your videos and then I go
straight to PvP like that's literally by
PvP is the first thing I do I knock
those five matches out I'm in there I'm
messing around and oh shut up the
service revolver right now I got me a
cup literally when I logged in got tell
you about that later but um yes yeah
it's it's crazy range range master work
kill clip all range finder all I was
doing things in Rumble it was just crazy
but anyway so like when I heard them
finally say PvP guys we know we you guys
have been neglected you've guys have
been thrown to the curb I needed to hear
it now out shadow dad oh shut out the
dad oh because he was bringing him
here's I guess some trials dallisa with
trial trials
is that what we're not really you know
they did that they did the market in
that tract that everybody said they said
like a few seasons we knew this is gonna
be season eight season I know we're
gonna see like it's gonna be December
January lower content like smaller
Annual Pass stuff there's gonna that's
there's gonna be a trials now see that's
a question so this season we got black
armory
mm-hmm gambit season of opulence PvE
hybrid PvE now not everyone in this game
loves PvP but currently this annual past
PvP really got neglected yes absolutely
will agree with that now there's a point
knee and you'll pass or some people like
hey you know buy this season and you get
trials and some people are like I'm not
a PvP person I'm not gonna do that do
you think like if they go season in
March is gonna be this is gonna be the
trials of the nine Osiris whatever they
call it now like when they bring it back
do you think that would be its own
season and everything in that season is
about PvP do you think they could
actually justify an expansion to
actually be that focus cuz they
basically did it with gambit so do you
think how do you think how do you think
there cuz honestly I would be that would
be like their mid season cuz gambit
didn't have a raid it was just a bad
there's not so Saints em I think you're
on it similar timing we're talking about
cuz when the hell was drifter March
March March April May so then June
starts no yeah
so March if you don't have that raid
somewhere in the middle you have at the
beginning you have a break in that
middle time somewhere either December or
March mm-hmm yeah like a child's season
like how do you think they're like about
go down I think it's one of those things
they can get away with it because at the
end of the day you know they're gonna
follow cadence where annual pass right
with just that this is really a
substantial first part so we're gonna
say this is almost a top heavy they're
gonna do uh you know what you call a
garage iron so to speak so um yeah I see
because in your defense right we can't
keep getting grades every single annual
yes it's just not sustainable busting up
here dad I agree with that it's not
sustainable
I completely agree so right after you're
gonna have to have something meaty but
at the same time that doesn't include a
raid and you have these assets you know
means so I could I could totally see
them doing that and that'd be the season
that would be about now three or four
seasons cadence coordinate when we last
spoke to them and they told us no no
trials no travel you know say so it's
about three four you know seasons now
come on yeah so look I think yeah I
think that's it I think if they I doubt
it it probably be about the nine most
likely I mean my dreams from a boy to
come back you know saying and get his
Redemption arc going on with Osiris but
I think it's too early I think honestly
I don't see Osiris in too deep I'm gonna
be honest as much as I want them
I don't think they bring him back you
know there's probably other things they
wanted so um but they can still bring
Charles back in some form you know and
make it kind of like the PvP so to speak
you know Dave because the key thing they
said and it did op was that he didn't
say no to dental about trials he just
said we have to clean up the house and
the foundation yep PvP first before we
bring that stuff in so the vibe I'm
getting with this season is that they're
going to at least attempt to do things
they they mentioned something like
playlists and functions yes that's what
I they stated to where I mean and Luke
Smith was like hey I'm gonna use a
terrible metaphor but it's actually a
really good one at least I thought it
was because you take a house the
important case is about how if you ever
go by a house by the way this is one
thing that got told to me it's one of
the most important things you can ever
listen to if you buy a house you can
change wallpaper you can change carpet
you can change like hardwood floors you
can change pictures that stuff doesn't
matter at all you need three things a
good foundation is frame and a roof
mm-hmm those are your three and that's
what they're talking about for PBP right
they need to found they need the frame
they need the stuff behind the walls not
like hey this game-mode is 20 second
timers or heavy and what comes up in 30
seconds no they're looking at the
playlist whether it's matchmaking
whether it's how the playlist function
whether it's quick play whether it's
like specific choices that you get
they're working on the base level stuff
for PvP mm-hmm too
feel better yes now if there are I don't
see here's the question as oh here we go
oh no I was just gonna ask as we're
talking about PvP I'm gonna think about
the foundation the foundation of PvP is
how you actually pair up with people
right dedica nervous when I'm out I
think that would be on the table I got
bad news for you I don't think I don't
think it would be either yeah as much as
I want it is it's just too much going on
right now
infrastructure wise between the influx
of the PlayStation and the Xbox
community just talk to each other
now we're talking PC now going to steam
bringing steam you know involved then
you're talking stadium with streaming
it's it did so many infrastructure so I
think that is completely d3 that's
that's long term vision I think like I
said cross say was the innovator
intermarry step where we kind of get
everybody together and playing a band
play what they want and that's cool d3
is that and it I would love it to be you
know I'm saying I would love it to be
the only thing though it's gonna still
be tough because bunch is on their own
the other end so indicates a cheap so
like during the at Division days we had
more of a reason to yell and say yo what
is up like why don't you have this and
that's really activist there was no
excuse right for them to not have
dedicated with as much money they make
hand over fist with these games Call of
Duty's and all that stuff enough money
if we didn't make a billion dollars more
than we thought we would god exactly
stop it right so you know that that to
me is the thing so I got to see how
they're gonna go with it but um yeah I
mean I I think right now they gotta
worry about just everyone playing nice
together with data as far as
transferring you know saying once they
prove that then d3 they tackle the next
big one yeah I mean they control the API
they control the data where you get your
stuff from and then it's how you
interact with you know their system it's
like if dim can interact with like your
inventory in your vault and stuff like
that so can playstation xbox data and PC
you can all talk to the same light and
where's your box of information okay I'm
pulling stuff from his box like that's
fine now the funny thing does he
actually said yeah do you actually think
we're stadiums from stadia is gonna be
cuz stadia is gonna be it's based on
their server so you're working on
controlling but they actually have
control of that server game right well
hey it was like I don't know how I don't
know the specific is how that all works
but you're not like they're not pure
matchmaking to my computer right you're
gonna match me to a server that Google's
running so it's like now Google is
dedicated now that Dizzy's got a point I
mean it's a possibility
the only issue comes down to your
communal connection and then if they
were to do that they would have to pony
up like dedicated servers or like I work
a cloud every dedicated servers on
sheet-like so shout out to the police
say they agree they're like oh it's
crazy it's crazy a little bit but anyway
so on yeah man it's like uh the only way
that happening is if that partnership is
truly exclusive and they say okay we if
we give you a meals and that's that way
if we give you um
destiny as an exclusive streaming
platform right then they could buncha
could turn around and said okay then you
give us a really discounted rate on um
dedicated servers right and to help
facilitate all this cross save stuff and
all that so it's a possibly I'm not
saying it's out the room I don't they
plus it would destroy my Microsoft
Theory all the way you don't say because
if that's the case then they will not be
able to use they will be the de facto
streaming platform which I still don't
think Bungie would do I still think
Bungie wants to gain to be on this many
devices many platforms as they possibly
can because it's beneficial to the
online population and the thriving of
the game foot we will see I mean I'll
tell you this let's just say they did do
the deal yeah I wouldn't be mad I mean
games still gonna be on Xbox anyway but
it's just a matter of if it's streaming
exclusive but let's just say they had
Google
some dedicated servers that's still a
win I still a win man
cuz now you're talking d3 setting up in
and future on connectivity on dedicated
servers I'd take it because we
definitely won dad lets me on you know
peer to peer it is what it is it's just
just not that great it's you know we
want to eliminate as much problems as we
as we can do what you do uh I mean it's
it's interesting because stadia need
stadia has that like timing they have to
figure out how they're gonna launch
window stadia launched like date wise
when is it life you know
yeah you're not gonna be playing yeah
stadia arrives this number mark at so I
thought mmm so it's not gonna be like
day in date obviously for destiny but
like how big of a game is destiny is not
small yeah I mean for them to be saying
that's up they stay D you have to have a
reason to buy stadia mm-hmm you're like
okay so it's 999 I might get this and
the other and they can pair in there as
well and it may sound cool in theory and
of course as you said not everybody is
going to have the connection to be able
to use it but Lindsey I think I don't
I'm wondering how much Bungie actually
had to pay is like hey if we want to
launch on stadia be like we've got an
expansion we have this new thing that
we're doing were this free to play
I don't know if they had to pay as much
as partner with them to be like hey
we're gonna help you launch your
platform as me just to be a partner it's
like because I mean they need they need
a substantial Blake set importantly
baldur's gate 3 teaser then you gotten
you go to stops behind them with Ghost
Recon breakpoint and then division
issues all we have are we sure us oh
three pillars of like major companies
but bunchy on their own saying hey can
is like let's work together and see cuz
we're trying to get this in everybody's
hands like I don't know if that I think
they're actually working together more
than being like hey let me pay to put
this on your platform can I have
dedicated service hey let's help launch
this thing together and like it comes
with the founders edition of cedi you
get destiny to with that that's a
selling point for them to say hey you're
gonna buy the controller that's seventy
dollars you're gonna get this chrome
Castle
which I don't know how much it cost I
got a look and you get a $60 game for a
hundred thirty bucks like the controller
in the game is 130 plucks press the cast
plus three months plus three months for
a friend like that [ __ ] they're using
they're using specifically destiny to
sell their product there is a reason X
so late I mean that's an impressive
choice for one Bungie yeah being like
hey we're Google we do crazy stuff we
picked Bungie and we picked destiny to
cold launch this thing like that's an
impressive like partnership right there
oh absolutely
like but but that's what I'm saying I
think that partnership will lead to
benefits for both sides now that Bungie
is like hey can I have just kind of like
service I'm like hey let's do this
together like and then you know maybe if
that partnership works well maybe they
can use Google servers or something like
that something like that down the road
so I think the stadia thing even like if
stadia functions or not which hopefully
it does I'm sure I'll try it at some
point but right I think just having
Google be a partner is huge for them to
be able to have oh I'd like stability
and stuff down the road so hopefully
really help them out
sorry long discussion you know this is
this is good discussion it's it's very
interesting to see this is where I need
hope this where we gotta get if we could
somehow get behind the scenes of that
contractual agreement which allowed what
is it a marketing deal for streaming is
it an exclusivity deal for streaming is
there is is there any talking about like
X cloud being an option and stuff like
that later on so you're wondering yeah
like hey if staties there's one that
streams otherwise you gotta buy your
digital your download copy and play it
normal as opposed right man cuz stadia
could say I mean if they want to be
aggressive in aidanu killing a bloody
the first kid on the block was streaming
right so they could say yo we'll do this
with you but we have to be the exclusive
streaming platform right we know steam
is now they've taken it taking it off a
battlenet right steam is gonna be the
de-facto PC platform right so who's
gonna get to Neos coming right there
they didn't know in specific that's the
lucky way heart on hardcore game they
did but remember we have to look at it
in the context of arm platform right
streaming represents a different entity
that's a new entity I'm not saying what
he's saying is wrong he could very well
write it
could still not be exclusive extreme
anywhere right but again we know X cloud
is coming right so the key is going to
be is Microsoft allowed with their
soon-to-be streaming platform to stream
destiny you know any question I would
say I know your mutant for the for the
love out there shout outs of the hard
workers in the world honestly I think
like the bunch he bought their
independence however they did it they
spent time to buy their independence and
I think at this point this is like hey
we're gonna pair up with Google to help
you know we're gonna use this as another
platform out there with but I also but I
don't think they're gonna say no you
can't stream this on Xbox or you can't
stream this on PS 5 thing or as your X
cloud or whatever all the infrastructure
is gonna be called I think it's gonna be
where you play destiny and I don't think
they would say oh well I got an Xbox
with X Club well you can't stream it
there I don't think they would do that
because of their messaging is so strong
to say play and unique that is one of
their three pillars they started with
that little elevator pitch yes is the
same so I don't think they would do that
so I was like obviously I know I was
like I understand like you're like hey
maybe they paid it's like I think
bunches at this point will help you
launch it but we still have our freedom
to put it wherever we want to I'm with
you it literally ties in to why I still
expect to see it on Microsoft stage or
announced by Microsoft at some point
when it comes you let get to say first
and we'll see we'll see when I go out
here but not I agree this is a great
discussion I just love tech stuff like
this I love hearing behind the scenes
how deals get done and and this stuff is
fun it's it's real fun because um like I
said just to see let's just call it what
it is them being on stadia is a good
move for visibility and more access for
the game at the end of the day however
this plays out it there's a whole
community that doesn't have a box that
doesn't have a high functional PC that
may have a potato of a rig you know I'm
saying and they say and you're saying
hey I can go on my phone I can go on my
tablet I can go on my browser all I have
to do and I'm just reading right now the
control is not mandatory you can
keyboard mouse it you can keyboard now
I've just read right now one of their
stadia go to the state account right now
that yeah they said are you good yeah so
literally you know you can do that's
crazy man that's a whole new player base
that is part of it you know that but it
don't play consulate don't play that's
that's gonna be privy to deci for the
first time and if the subscription is
what it is and they just buy that
whatever ten hours whatever it is amok
that's hey you got you may have a new a
whole new base no influx of people you
know indeed didn't Bungie break by the
way Oh nope they're just okay okay hmm
I'm just waiting to see if we'll just
get it twelve at some point probably not
yeah so I mean I think at this point
they are going out of their way to say
we're gonna be wherever you want to be
so that free to play but honestly for
them I mean think about if you you don't
get the founders but you just do the
$9.99 do you think that's gonna come
with the new light or do you think
that's gonna come with shadow key I
think you're probably just new light I
think they're trying to the vibe I'm
getting from the the messaging is the
packaging is they want you to get that
whole package for shadow keep mmm so
yeah again if I had to guess you know
I'm gonna spacey looking at it right now
is I think that that's the route most
likely they're gonna go with yeah yeah
this is a interesting times man this is
interesting times love it love it
shadow keep next gen with stadia
collects from the stadia pro so here is
when you look at the standard edition of
Shenmue ki wherever you buy it however
you get around to getting your hands on
shadow keep this is what its gonna
contain one destiny two shadow keep does
not require ownership of any previous
destiny two expansions to play don't
even have to have touched anything don't
even need would have skipped um forsaken
still played you're good now features
now there's a specific inclusion and
exclusion that I want to talk about here
just get to it new missions and quests
it's gonna be a campaign we know it's
gonna be sometimes a story to this thing
going in figure out what eras did what
she messed up when she Barry
Quest's we know those are gonna be there
and that's gonna be like whether it's
exotics whether it's like here's the
side mission or things like that new
destination we know is gonna be the moon
twice as big yep there's my other baby
alright though yeah new dungeon fire
oh now in that little V doc do you did
you get where you think that dungeons
gonna be I didn't catch put me on my
hunch in their discussion being is kind
of mentioned separately
mmm-hmm black garden yes because it sent
that discussion sounded at of exact same
they were talking about new dungeon
they're running around of the black
garden and they're like well that's not
anyway related to the moon that's a
Venus and Mars some weird combination in
the middle that's separate so if that's
the dungeon I think send me there
dungeons are amazing so new dungeons so
that's a happy man right there yeah I
don't know that is a happy man right
this is shattered throw fields just came
back well okay either way they say
there's a dungeon and a raid in the same
couple bullet points so wherever it
happens we'll see new armor and gear of
course all an all new raid not [ __ ]
oh they said the raid was black garden
in blue so maybe the raid is in black
garden okay by the way yeah this is all
about the nightmares and shadow keeping
the story connects and you're talking
about having these nightmares is the
black garden like is the little floating
orb that in the black garden that we
killed is that what's been like fueling
all these nightmares this is this is
news to me they got a tire my god that's
kind of why he's yeah he did say that to
cut you they did say I don't know if you
caught this laughing Luke said it what
the thing that they loved about forsaken
was how you did all that and then you
did the raid and then you saw the dream
in city and the curse of the psyche of
all of you of all so that you don't say
like did this literally black garden
something
that's gonna make us go to something
garden whether it's a dungeon and that
was the thing about the dungeon in
Forsaken it was very connected to that
three-week cycle story mm-hmm like that
was tied in like doing like the lore
behind that is actually bananas when you
hear like why is there a week cycle
happening when we kill Dylan car we
start over and we do the three week
cycle again like the lore behind that
whole sequence whether it's annoying
that you only have two three weeks to
play it anyway the fact that how that
sight the reason that cycle is there is
bananas so if the dungeon actually has
any lower connotations whether the raid
is in black garden or the dungeon isn't
black if there's some connection between
all that insanity mmm whoa always eNOS
craziness and the war black jack is
saying carrier Korea and the vex mmm
that could be because they finally give
some tie-in to the other planets like so
I don't know so the dungeon like dungeon
for me has me obviously hyped I will
throw my money at the screen long ago
yeah the seriously thrown my wallet at
the baby let's go
season pass for the season of the
undying we got the name it was actually
if you look in the game right now it's
in there if you go closer season seven
and they say everything about season
seven I'm opulence on the bottom season
on dying like next season season I'm
dying so it's actually already been out
there mmm-hmm a pre-order destiny to
shadow keep on playstation or xbox one
and receive dusting to chrysalis iris
and war mine to begin playing today so
you can actually start doing that
pre-purchased who also receive the two
tailed fox exotic rocket launcher and an
exclusive hive themed ornament once
destiny to shadow keep launches so
that's like an interesting little it's
just they're giving you a lot I don't
know ocean of Destiny to shadow keep
includes a digital copy of the game and
a single season pass providing exclusive
activities and awards first purchase per
account for the asterisks mmm-hmm also
we Quakers include a touch not to cut
you finally comment on the death of
exclusive exotics at exclaim oh my god
yes thank
no more exclusive that stops in
September who ever is there's still a
strike that we haven't played on PC is
there there's one isn't there yeah
there's one
well hey see there you go there's your
new strike now I'm really excited it
says missions quest dungeons
destinations they're gonna talk about
PvP what I don't see in there
mm-hm strikes yeah hi I was just about
to say - I don't see strikes yep I see
strikes take the El on that I had to
take the El on that because I'm
acquiescing to you there's only so much
they can do
yes ed so listen if you--if listen if I
got if I gotta say do I want strikes in
the whole shebang or wait I take this
I'm good I'm not gonna Dave they're
really given a lot you know I'm saying
and listen you know I missed strikes I
really do I really do but you know maybe
what the hope is maybe with the next
season postseason up the old and dying
we we could we could put money then we
gonna say most likely it's not going to
be a raid
right after I would think that would be
a lot that would be season of opulence
raid sees them undying raid and then
another that would be a lot to ask so
yeah cuz I'm gonna last
who made black armor I'm trying to
remember who made that because I know
vicarious made season of opulence and I
don't know if they had help with black
home because I mean the last wish was
Bungie mmm so then if there was another
like for black army they made the labs
and they made the skirts of the past so
that was like that was back-to-back
raids in three months
and then they had the six month break
obviously tell opulence so you get a
raid now then ones your raid what was
the timeline the timeline for armed
league at December
mmm when do we get armored in December
December yeah um I would say December
whatever you know the season comes out
that can they cannot be that that is too
many rates they they need a break hit
take the to reload yes yes listen I
could
because I got no relative maybe they
need a break game do you mean middle do
you put it March do you put it not like
your June thing properly um like do it
when the accepted after was March after
as March yeah see the keys do you think
they but it's like if your raid goes in
March and that's a PvE focused thing
where do you put your PV P trial season
situation I'm curious to see big curve
balls yeah yeah I love it love it though
you know like I'm curious to see if
Annual Pass keeps the decadence of three
months three is a lot well if you scroll
down when you get to the shadow keep
digital deluxe edition it comes with
everything you need nor oh yeah foresee
for season passes Wow
now you get one you get your seat you
get season eight with shadow keep so
that's basically a season and you get
everything in there specifically but
there are four Wow
that's they are working I gotta shut up
they are working like this is like I'm
not you to be honest now I'm like oh how
y'all doing this this sounds like way
too much like I'm like what do I got
trying to work on d3 oh we're talking
we're coming full circle all the way
back to the ocean
oh go for circle Rayman like for season
passes that's all why not three this is
interesting this is interesting could
look well for one is included with
shadow key so you still have you still
it's like the annual pass just literally
season eight is right there and with
shadows so that would be one right what
and then you yeah so it's the full year
of what we just went through its
forsaken season afford seasons drifter
season opulent it's another yeah no
you're right you're right I'm sorry it's
not like you're doing three-month
seasons
okay right so basically Xia countenance
so basically is to say so basically
shadow keep is the equivalent of
forsaken which can
as one yep okay I got it good all right
so that it's the same yeah it's I guess
uh it's interesting because all I'm
doing in my mind is trying to line up
when d3 is going to launch Yeah right so
when I see this cuz I don't know for
some reason I thought maybe d3 end of
2020 right or psi xx Xbox - yeah that
seems fitting yeah now we know it I
don't see d3 I think they have to take a
break after the fourth one which would
be the summer of 2020 which would be the
season of opulence right season last
season opulence - if we're going once
for yes yes season of operas 2020 I
don't think you could come back again
and say boom Raza fired right that is
when I go I defer to you now and say you
have to NextGen's out right cuz
September next-gen won't be a you think
I don't get a launch this is my gut
again it could be wrong look my gut
tells me September there's no shadow
keep - because November there's gonna be
the new consoles right we're gonna have
the PlayStation 5 and we'll have the
Xbox Scarlett or what have you
right I don't this is tough this is
tough because they kind of did do that
with destiny - cuz didn't destiny to
launch regular I'm plugging I'm trying
to remember what was destiny - old
generation was out of it
try to remember now it's so it's gotta
go back in time let me know what a
PlayStation came out in 2014
yeah yeah it was already out you already
crossed a generation Ross you know this
is interesting this is interesting
because at some point they have to prep
d3 for next-generation consoles can I
have that in writing since you know but
that's what I've been trying to say this
entire time yeah but this boy
the affor season you're even looking at
that saying hey that sounds like a lot
to keep up with we saw how pvp was now
neglected and they mention as to why
they're seeing all these pieces they are
on their own they do not have other
Studios where do you have so I don't
know it's a so my question is like so
then you're saying like they have to
take a break to prep for d3 how does
that break work that's what I've been
asking for a while it's like how do you
see that break functioning they have to
basically after the season say okay all
hands on deck for there will be no more
season after the fourth this fourth
season the shadow key and say all hands
on deck for 2021 launch or less they
keep some time it's all about Katie this
is a weird thing it's very serious this
is now this brings it right back so what
she described is what I had predicted
this year is you're just saying it's
okay next year basically what I'm saying
is it all depends on when they feel
comfortable launching d3 it doesn't
basically what they've shown so far is
that they don't care they're dropping
September this is what this is what I
learned because let's be real we've had
this discussion about like yo do not
drop when they come you see the copy
here the cops they like don't do it
don't drop out here tonight so anyway so
basically it's like now they're saying
yeah we're gonna drop in September
regardless who's out there that's ballsy
to me this is a new Bungie I wasn't
expecting this right this changes the
landscape now now to me it says well
maybe they they still keep this cadence
all the way through so that's like but
it was like so okay so in your mind the
cadence has changed but you're also
saying season of opulence to whatever
season 2020 is you're saying that's okay
so if they don't do a September launch
then and they wait for if they need to
prep for d3 is that them didn't really
like hey if they don't release anything
else
everybody's gonna forget about them then
okay I take it back to that line of what
you gave me a hard time about
obviously because you're just like hey
they need to prep for d3 they need to
take a break there's not gonna be
another September expansion that's
literally what I said about the
September coming up and you're like no
they're gonna forget about them but you
just said it's okay in 2020 so I'm
asking I was saying I was saying it's
okay under the impression that they
would not drop I did not think they were
gonna drop in September I'll be honest
like there was no way in my mind there
go Borland's they're gonna go up against
all these heavy hitters and they just
sit there and broke the internet today
they said we don't feel like it was so
gangster what they did they were like so
what and I'm like and what's funny is up
like yeah like this now my mind is blown
like yeah I could do whatever you want
so I'm literally in all right now this
is uncharted territory deal mentally up
Portland soda boy like they they're so
what like this was the most gangsters
thing I've ever seen I'm like you dare
not drop around that time so now that
changes the whole scope of the argument
now because to me it's like they're
gonna continue to drop when they want to
drop and if you continue to work on d3
when they want to work on and they give
it a 4 season passes like there's no
need there's no crunch they're acting
like they're under no jurisdiction to
have to wait that's what I'm saying like
now I don't know I'm trying to give them
a break and they like now we're out here
we're good no so here's the other way
they can play it and this is what I want
if they do it's the four season passes
mmm what if those aren't on a very
specific cadence what if it what if they
take little breathers in between to
space them so they release them when
they're ready so it is like no just so
so say shadow keep gets through through
December instead you have September
October November December they have some
other events and then the next season is
January did they space them a little
farther yeah get some breather in
between so it's not like a three-month
cadence like Bam Bam Bam Bam it's like
in grant a little breather bank and
there's a little more breathing room in
there survive them that time to function
so then it's
not on this Lake and that would let them
also break off of that September cycle
if they want to that would just be
another way for them to do it as opposed
to every three months we have a new
season in this like wrecked environment
and that may be what they want to do but
they also have the freedom to say hey
season of whatever's after shadow keep
em hmm we want a little more time to
work on it
hang tight for the next month that's
gonna be in January instead what say he
said they but one side he said it might
not know there's definitely gonna be d3
though cuz he did they did got oppressed
Luke Smith yeah and he pressed him on d3
specifically and he gave the typical
corporate answer which is we're not
ready to talk about that right now
you know we're we're so far ahead so
it's common it's definitely I did think
it was gonna go mmm on memo all the way
and this is what they're doing is just
gonna stay here but yeah d3 is
definitely gonna come um yeah yeah I
think you're on it I think your honor I
think that might be the new wave which
is basically throw out the outside of
this September which is following
cadence yeah maybe they say go we wait
until it's ready the next content which
would be our what's a black armory part
two right black armory part two cadence
does it necessarily have to come out
December and then they say yo you know
I'm saying we push that back or maybe is
that January February and you space out
the cadence of that and that could
totally that could totally work because
again they're free from Activision you
know that's another way they can do it
it's just interesting to me when I
didn't see this part that's why when you
show me this and I see the digital
collectors stuff and it's saying four
season passes like I didn't expect that
I be honest I didn't expect it was gonna
let me keep that hmm so yeah the joys of
speculation timing continues mm-hmm and
then two things if you go to the Bungie
store the end the collector's edition
for shadow key which it has a cool thing
they say a high of crypto glyph which is
solvable by what comes in the
collector's edition it's actually a
little puzzle box but you're going to
spin figure out the key and open and I
guess decipher live
to be able to actually understand what's
coming next but there's another piece
you can buy that stuff without buying a
game code you can buy everything in the
collector's edition if you want it
separately yes yes no game code version
or taking a look at it right now
so you got a couple patches you got some
books in there I can't quite tell what's
involved it's got the soundtrack and the
game and that's enough so that will
definitely probably be a thing on what
do you think buggy buggy yeah on the
page yeah I don't know what that look
you're showing so the Mars rover we
found it da Vinci Code yeah that's
exactly what I was thinking black we
like twisty puzzle box thing
so yeah you got quite a bit of its what
one what is that 129 for that thing mmm
[Music]
150 150 I'm sorry for the full
collectors which will come with the
digital deluxe which is 60 and then I
guess it's so 90 bucks on top for
everything it comes with steam up here
looks good looking good oh yeah steam
took no time at all by the way it's on
top page on Steve that was lowkey that
was lowkey yeah epic storm what Loki
Loki we know that was like Borderlands 3
and seems like destiny to me he was like
we got no problem going up against you
with that what's up yo man
gangster bro like I didn't expect this
is I would I was perfectly content with
them tuck and tail and I'd have been
okay with it like nah we him and we this
is wow this is this is something so what
all did we get we've got shadow keep
we've got new light we've got cross play
we've got destiny 2 is going to steam
mmm that's everything we got going
forward which is a whole bunch I'm gonna
have to watch that vitac again me too
yeah really really really slowly to
understand the armor pieces how that
works and I'll break that now and at
some point in the future stadia blew the
doors off of it first
cross save they say watch this space for
how cross
we'll work because at some point uh it's
just gonna what hey he's like he's like
JA see you with my three max Guardians
to September can't wait to run with you
guys get the that's what I was talking
about earlier forty I mean again forget
the content forget even though the
content looks at me everybody the same
looks amazing all the gameplay just a
head alone isn't earth-shattering I must
say something crazy II uh-oh I'm say
some crazy 400 I'm fairly confident
ready I'm feeling like a bit of leg so
what would a little a feeling confident
I can't believe I've got full service I
went from running in hiding to like yo
we out here like bring it at this point
what you gon do I got the whole kögel
what you gonna do when the cross save
come for you why don't you because at
the end of the day no disrespect the
ball ends great game we're gonna pick it
up no disrespect right it looks fun but
when is done it's done right and at the
end of the day you're talking about all
my friends looking forward to all these
people that are destiny hardcore desti
people there's people that love both but
now you're telling the cat aliens and
everybody that love Borderlands know
like yo one week after get your fun four
good days four days four days that is so
go ahead go go over there and then you
go have to come back over I love it this
is a probable this is such a Power Move
wow wow didn't see this coming salute
the Destin just when I got a stick it's
the Phoenix its rises from the Phoenix
every time you think it's dead its back
again crazy how things work Wow
who woulda thought we'd be having this
conversation uh yeah I honestly didn't
did not know but no like I mean the
free-to-play way to get into it you've
gotten it looks so good like so much
positive stuff coming soon I honestly
can't wait but we still have to talk
about what just came out
so how okay so season of opulence we
finally made it to the topic because we
just basically said hey new stuff in the
future it counts more than right now and
that's probably true for a lot of you
guys but we still got to talk about
seasonal opulence how much have you
touched it not much brother this is
gonna be be listening to you at the
fireplace
right now but I'm I'm got to tell me
brother Oh literally all I did with get
my invitation I went to the barge you
know barely got shot around a few things
but you tell I haven't even seen them
but not breaking down what's the
menagerie like tell me what was it like
out him yeah so the menagerie is kind of
Awesome actually and Chris Wow is so
it's got mechanics to it there's rooms
there's timers on it it's I you go
through it twice it's not there there
you'll set encounters have variations to
them you won't have the same order of
encounters the final boss seems to be
the same that's where the bosses are
gonna be changing as they rotate those
in so what is the menagerie well it
starts for one season of opulence
lunches a lot of people are just
leveling up just like I was trying to
get into the raid 24 hours that didn't
happen that thing was largely but that
six hour cried God so okay so the six
hour grind the contest modifier is an
interesting thing okay breakin that sets
a difficulty and it doesn't matter if
you were 750 the contest modifier is
gonna make you seven hundred when you
fight that first encounter and they can
pick whatever they want the enemies to
be they were 715 720 that stuff hurt you
had to be on point precision couldn't I
had to execute together we didn't mind
the people I leveled up with we even
went in that next afternoon after most
of us were like 7:15 7:20 hoping to be
ready for the like then it couldn't even
be the first encounter Wow so that set
that contest modifier took like just
damn near perfect execution because if
you died a lot of the way that raid
works spoiler warning I'll give you guys
about five seconds four three two one is
the fact that you
basically it's called a buff it's a
witch's blessing half the team will have
it half won't and you're splitting up
into Tritton to do little duo's and both
of you have to be alive because the
things you need to shoot and do stuff
with is you need both of you so say
there's three crystals each crystal has
to be shot by a person with and without
the blessing in your life change and who
has the blessing all the time so you
have these little duo's that are going
the whole time but if you one of you
dies that crystal can't get killed left
seven he comes over and covers and then
you got a finger it did you have the
blessing and did you not so dying was
just awful and you were so squishy at
that level that was why it was is Bertil
now I didn't get past the first
encounter I know there's a jumping
puzzle and some stuff like that and then
the boss is to say though that so I
haven't seen the jumping puzzle at all
actually and the boss is like phase one
and then phase two kind of like skirts
of the past it has a similar look I
think so it's got one jumping puzzle
phase one phase two for the bosses so I
think it's basically scourge in length
once people get it down yeah yep but you
are gonna have to those mechanics Shadow
the pyro I was talking to him for a
second kind of more annoying on the
mechanics like not as fake yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna go there I watched it I
did watch um dad Oh second place drink i
watch so I felt felt bad but not to do
today they crushed it it cuz I just want
to see could busy i watch esoterics
final encounter for the win
then I watched arrows entire run right
so when I saw the first encounter I
liked it I just felt it went too long
I felt like at the for lanterns yeah it
takes we got so shot at the bender and
chat and mmm the rest of the team it was
Hampton and summer and a little bender
yeah mayor and then me me toes that was
just the ones that I had and the six of
us we got to halfway through the first
encounter mm-hmm so yeah it was like we
got the mechanics we had it down kind of
had a different strata we got later on
in that afternoon the next day that was
kind of helping but execution is so key
now if I went in now at like 7:25 on
that first encounter
you wouldn't be a squishing we could
probably go do it that's why I still
want to try Josh this weekend so see how
it is a level of the contest cap mm-hm
and I think that's one of those things
if they want to launch that rate now
they have the contest that's like I
don't care if you level priming Graham
what you could give like in two weeks
and then just slap that contest modifier
on there and even if you're 750 it
doesn't matter you're still gonna play
that rate at the level they want you to
play you for the rate race and then
after that then it can be fine and
normal and then people might go stop it
I guess at a higher level but that
contest
rade race would be curated so whatever
they pick okay so they go you that later
but I was like just forcing it in six
hours for one that whole like picture
and spreadsheet that people are saying
hey playing the stuff on all three
character dreaming CD and shout it you
don't have six hours to do all that
stuff I'm sorry that was not gonna
happen on three characters now maybe the
people who were up there got there but I
got pretty lucky by the time was rate
was coming around I was about seven
fifteen and I got lucky
I got lucky on drops I started to get
screwed after we kind of we're doing
some of the other stuff and I got like
four energy weapons in a row and that
happened later but I mean right
generally for me it was it's too fast to
force that and the best way to do that
is go play old stuff so you didn't you
reinvigorate that whole like argument of
people saying hey this is that whole
thing of you know the leveling has
issues and going to play the old content
and stuff like that you forced people to
do that if people got to play the
menagerie and then hey I'll go get to do
this and had a couple casual weeks to go
play some content some of the new stuff
Experion with menagerie and then like
hey if you're over level cool we're
still gonna set this contest and then
you go I still think that would be a
better way to do that
the contest is cool because it levels it
like first encounter you're 700 I don't
care if you're 750 and in that last
encounter you're 720 fight and seven
thirty-five whatever they set it at
that's fine you'll fine with that that's
I mean however they decide to do that in
theory that does level the playing field
which is cool but then in turn it just
forced you to like just burn yourself
out for six hours and then when you got
into the grind you already like like you
were kind of like drained just grinding
for light then to turn around
start grinding for the raid for however
many hours and then shout out to be bold
Caroline gamer esoterics I know there's
other people those are the two I
remember in the dados math class and
slayer age like that was the closest one
to finish they said they've ever had
yeah they didn't mention that yeah and I
will say by the way if you're tapping
your foot on your desk you're shaking
your camera
sorry just saying I cut myself doing it
before so yeah it treat on the carpet so
they're late let me shout out to them
executing under the contest modifier
because it whooped us on the first one
so they put that together and had
everything I want to back you up I want
to back you up
so you're a fan of the first I mean the
contest rules the conflict not a fire is
nice is it could use some tweaks for
lighting how the level it makes but if
they want to make it an even fight and
that's the I mean give people time to
level up so like grinding in six hours
still leaves a lot of room for orangey
to screw you over so like in six hours
you have a lot of room over the course
of like a week or something like that
orangey would have a chance to kind of
level itself out for a lot of people but
then if you slap the contest modifier on
one week later orangey or not you are
gonna base if you've been playing enough
you should probably be okay in a week
like I got to I got the 720 in couple
days there's a lot of crap and ways to
get powerful gear and the menagerie is a
new one we'll get to in a minute right
and you're saying I don't think they
want people to get some of the powerful
weapons before the raid and like that
that is one of those things but as like
I don't think there's too much out there
that's gonna break the raid overall that
you would probably get in that first
week but that raid itself is you could
be higher you could just let people
breathe a little more then you could be
like okay everybody's ready take your
day off goings fresh BAM
reset go for the raid but that but that
contest modifier sets it so I don't care
how high you are everyone faces that
first encounter the same then it is
understanding the raid then it isn't
working together execute against a team
on a level playing field but you don't
have to like bash your head against the
grind for
X hours to try and get as high as
possible still maybe have our NGS screw
you over maybe be a little bit under
level even though we're all supposed to
be even so you're okay okay I get what
you're saying are you saying your main
thing is that grind that six hour just
line commitment is just too short you
know I'm saying so what about what do
you say to the people I feel you coming
from I guess my counter-argument would
be what do you say to the people and I
say look you know you gotta take the day
off if you want to do if you want that
world first you gotta I don't know you
know the hard core whatever like cuz the
vibe I got again just looking for me
house I'll be I was a little surprised
that it was kind of like the same people
it was it like I thought it would be I
mean as someone I'm no disrespect like
they'd have they been in the mix before
you know would be bold and those guys
like I'd be I mean in rain mixes before
when I talked to CG for a little bit
Carolina gamer yeah a little bit and
diems and stuff just as I think they
were a little help on something else
yeah he said to me PvE is a huge thing I
mean obviously we know esoteric is for
sure
so I mean yeah it's like so playing with
that group PvE is there things so I mean
I think they may have tried before I
don't know if you were like you know
getting like decent top finishes and
stuff but not quite there obviously glad
was still in their data was still in
there those guys may have been trying
may not just have had same execution or
leveling or anything like that before
but I mean I think they have been trying
before so I don't know if they're I mean
they have some damn skilled people on
that team knows that's why I was like I
wasn't surprised when I heard when I saw
the list and I saw those two on there
alone I was like okay yeah that for sure
but yeah I don't know if there was a lot
of underdogs
Katka still got first one on console
nice like it still seemed like a lot of
the same yeah that's the Riptide out
world's first hmm I'm just surprised by
I mean that's why be obviously cream is
gonna rise to the top we know that but I
was I was just interested to see with
all this new you know contest rules so
to speak i'ma call it that um if that
would change up and we would get a new
face and it didn't really seem not that
that's a bad thing I mean these guys are
just that good I mean just we gotta give
it up to what it what it is I'll just
I'm just curious about that and um you
know and
reference to the whole six-hour thing
I'm with you I feel you I mean I knew
first time out my schedule just printed
I'm prepping for e3 you're like you know
and I'm I try my best to like try to say
everything was going wrong it was no way
I could all right I'm just gonna give it
up I'm gonna watch you guys imma cheer
on some the sidelines and see what's
going on
and what I've determined from me
there's no unless the stars align and
I'm off work and there's nothing going
on and boom you know I'm saying I'll do
it but other than that it to me seems
like a special type of commitment and I
think that's just what it comes down I'm
not saying that you're not committed cuz
clearly you are you know I'm saying so I
guess I don't know I guess it's just you
gotta have a sixth so that's what I'm
saying if you're looking to widen the
playing field yeah talk to me give you
give them a week or ten days like they
did for last wish but slap contest on
there so even if you're above
everybody's that in a level playing
field or people like you who are work
but you're like hey I can grind out
Friday Saturday said guys I'm not social
this weekend I'm working on leveling up
I am gonna like the only day I still
take off is that rough grind day but
more people get a chance to get up there
now I fade but like the people like be
bold like glad like math class all those
guys still take the time to be like hey
we run raids we think together we
execute we're damn skilled players like
there is something you can't like having
the time to get ready is still not gonna
make that mm like those people are gonna
be like they're extremely skilled
players but giving like orangey and
things like that and more and more
people like that group can pull it
through because those people have done
it before but if people just trying to
figure out puzzles and mechanics and
things like that and everybody like
there was that mix yeah I feel you I
feel any people are we're seeing that
waited for it to be beaten so they could
go into last wish they could go into
scourge and they could have a lot more
because that elastic last encounter was
kicking everybody's butt yeah I think I
think so it's literally just the level
so if everybody got to fight B
encounters that 707 10 720 or whatever
the numbers are in between I don't know
if everybody was above that enough to
where everybody had an even fight yeah
that would truly be like there's no
quite ultimately
and you get a week and a half to get
there okay yeah you're gonna have to
play you're gonna have to commit and if
you're on vacation that one may not
happen but if you do have some time in
that window three or four days switch
off a couple characters play a couple
hours a night get yourself ready then
that one day you still take off you know
but ever it it widens it I think that
would be the only thing that whitens it
and I think say no to rage I listened to
his he was like literally the same thing
like that he was like I like the contest
could use some tweaks but the six out
windows too short and it was like
nothing biggest thing I agree now having
experienced that - okay so then what
about this I don't before I know it be
today I just got actual one what about
this on Tuesday launch what about Friday
with contest rules so you got maybe
three days yeah three days not enough
for you so in it whatever you still cap
you first encounter second you know last
encounter whatever why would you have
time in three days yes three days give
me time one of them yeah but at the end
of the day you're still gonna be capped
right you are cap to a point but I'm
saying this week right now wouldn't be
given you have enough time there's no
way no you have had enough time I would
have played if I wasn't travelling me
for you that's that yeah like III is a
naught example but I'm just saying like
three days or even just a week like
you're kind of getting to the point
where the shorter the window the more
orangey can screw people if you get like
six gloves and four energy weapons and a
low you're like sitting here at the same
thing yeah like eight of my power drops
and I'm kind of screwed like there's
almost the point where if you go like a
full extra a week like if you did the
ten days like last wish but you like
you'll be fine but that contest levels
of playing fields first and you may be
able to jump in and be over leveled
which they may not want to and that's a
balance idle right and that's the other
side I don't know like that's it but for
that first time through more than six
hours three I don't know even for like
36 oh not a death three days to 72 hours
sorry to scoot was that enough like I
got there and I know how much I played
mm-hmm but it just like what if they did
it on a damn
Saturday what if they did it on like a
Saturday at noon less people probably
had to take off at work it's not in the
middle of a week I know they like
watching it up at a Bungie theater but
they live there
go drive watch you do that once a
quarter I think you guys can go back to
work and watch it in the theaters like
but no it's like I mean my level didn't
matter I was going in 7:15 and I still
felt squishy so the contest modifier
took execution is my point
absolutely so like that's the point
where I don't think it would have
mattered for us just because I was
feeling squishy and just it's hard and
it was a hard thing to execute pert like
there can't be a flaw like I'm staying
the wrong spot and fire-eyed I'd do a
night's fire like you can't do that like
you have to be perfect with that thing
on so I don't know how to solve the
problem of after the raid launches
people being over leveled and making it
too easy you still have to execute but
it would be too easy but I think
leveling the more time you give before
it launches levels the playing field
better is my opinion so like mine would
be about a week if I had the if I had to
pick a time frame it would be a week I'm
think I'm leaning with the three or four
days but I'm gonna be mad if they did it
because we remembered also did the other
reason why I think a week works what
you're saying in conjunction with the
raid be an extensive like a last wish
but if these raids are to me these are
little bigger than raid layers and I I
think that is really what when I saw
like three major encounters in I'm
saying yeah you know the suitcases the
first is what the jumping puzzle I
haven't seen but yes you know me so I
really I did yeah you know so I mean you
know it's an experiment we'll see if
they if they tweak you know main thing
if they want to you know do anything
like that but um yeah I definitely would
like to see more people in the mix but
you know charlatan I'm glad they did
they think even with restrictions in six
hours
you know shout to them there was no way
I was outside I'm just not a possibility
yeah so I can shout out to both of them
just like both teams going nuts right in
there
so it was not an easy thing when that
contest modifier I don't think there are
a lot of people out there with that
emblem so we'll see now as the grind
already happened for a lot of people
like people are to a point where now if
you went back in at this level at a
normal light maybe will be given a
decent amount red jackets out there
we'll see so I would like to still try
for that jacket so yeah it's five the
other piece is the menagerie oh yeah
break it down but again so the menagerie
basically you get the invitation and
this is how they did it too it's on all
characters that the power-boost works so
as you go through the quest of the
menagerie it starts sending gear that
you're picking up at 690 sends it to the
other two I saw it pop into my oh nice -
so you're just getting 690 on the other
characters so nice so it it gets you in
there pretty quick it's a quest about
the chalice you go out do a couple
things it's pretty straightforward
there's a little so Benedict is
basically or no it's actually a new guy
it's like Werner ninety-nine forty it's
the dude on the barge the big gold ship
and that's the thing that's where you go
is the barge and talk to this the other
robot but Calais is talking through the
robot yes oh you wanted your connection
you had the voice lines from Calais it
wasn't quite a cinematic out you had
that something a soul yep missile his
little hive have invaded we're here
we're doing so that's there was at least
the voice lines to explain that that was
cool
so the way I'll go chalice further I'll
go menagerie first and then I'll go
chalice this is the complicated piece
mm-hmm would shout out to nearest follow
that man on Twitter he's gonna have some
fun infographics when all the stuffs
figured out mmm it's not quite as crazy
but I know there's probably gonna be
some specific ones yeah the menagerie is
I have to think of it I'm trying to
think of the egg counters I've had one
two three four there's like five or six
different encounters mm-hmm and they're
all timed the farther do you have like a
bar that you fill and you start over
here and like the first encounter you
kind of suck and you only get here but
the side of the counter you like
completely knock out and you make more
progress on that bar and then you're
like okay so I got here
and then if the third encounter you do
well you've only got three but if you
like shorten them up you might have more
time in four encounters and then it
finally steers you back to the boss room
so the encounters I've had two different
counters be different or one encounter
have two different variations but
everything's time to the mechanics
aren't too crazy they're pretty sorry
forward there's one where you're just
trying to hold down plates basically by
being overrun by lots and lots of stuff
but it like escalates the longer you're
there there's try and we're trying to
get through these things without the
time running out which I haven't done
any of those yet because the bosses just
keep getting crazier and crazier so
light level is gonna be a thing to be
able to be powerful in there and then
even the boss mechanics aren't too crazy
and the boss doesn't have a time limit
on him so if you you finally work
through the encounters you get back to
the boss room people seem to coordinate
and it's more just seems about survival
I haven't experienced the point where
I've lost one yet I've only done a few
but I haven't lost okay but there's one
for example like you're running around
there's nights normal nights with like
the chicken break yeah as you're walking
along they won't beat the hell out of
you and nearly one shot you so you got
to shoot those from a little bit of
distance but they drop a sword a hype
sword then there's Knights walking
around that have a actual projected
shield on them you can break that with
the sword then when they then when the
shield drops then everybody can damage
them so then you know getting a lot of
more people so soon as the Knights die
then you get swords and more people of
swords running around then the Knights
turn into ogres with shields now the
owners actually don't smash you as much
if you're smashing them a lot yeah then
you're breaking those shields so it
escalates like the levels and then I
think I got someone we didn't kill it
but I saw like a named ogre which might
be the final one in the sword encounter
right there's another one like our ghost
you pick up these little void skulls and
you have to break purple crystals with
your beam but those things will also
just wreck the enemies so it's your
timing and how quick can you get through
the waves of crystals and not die then
there's a little mini bosses at spawn
but no matter if you don't make it
through in a full encounter whatever the
length of total whatever like progress
you make in that thing it adds it to
your bar of like progress for all of the
menagerie so first when you make it
through like oh we did really crap you
first of you just a tiny chunk second
one we almost got the boss down we got
like you know a third of the bar instead
of like BB a tenth or something like
like you get a much bigger chunk if you
do well so that was one thing so if you
do like a crappy one a pretty good one
and in really amazing one you might be
done with those like wait the three
section done in three so it's not let me
ask you a quick question on [ __ ]
successful completion it's based on
progress within each thing which is nice
yeah so and it's random
so like you'll go through and I like
I've done the sword first and then I've
gone and I went down and held the little
platforms then I've gone and done the
thing where you're running through the
beams of light and gathering up stuff so
like you'll go in a different order
every time - mm-hmm it's the matchmaking
is there I could see her oak being dicey
so I can definitely kind of see why
you're gonna want the pre-made for that
mm-hmm and heroic is gonna be a thing -
so that's like that's the kind of the
way it overall works you go through
Howard me however many encounters it
takes for you to fill your bar you fill
it right after that then you go to the
boss we're gonna get a new boss on
Tuesday okay and then the week after we
in another boss so those will be
potentially maybe on rotation maybe
they'll be I'm hoping they're random in
the end honestly like once the bosses
unlock I'm hoping they're random so they
give time for people to experience and
understand them and then if I go do
three in the same day I'm hoping they're
random because fighting the same boss
multiple times the same day it does get
a little old if that's the only one
you're gonna fight all week so I'm
hoping as they unlock that those are
random - because everything else is
random in the order you fight and I've
seen a couple variations and things like
that so that's actually pretty cool so
let me ask you this in reference to last
question I know it's early
you know you've been rocking for a few
days but I guess my question is versus
escalation protocol where the wiz it's
sitting in pocket as far as a you know
an activity and you know a cooperative
activity so far like where just early
feel what's your ranking what of those
types of things
yeah like obviously we got blind well we
we got hopeless for me
depends how the bosses come in there's
at least three if there weren't as many
bosses but there are
I know escalation is more desolation or
above it mmm mouth okay no like because
there's a lot of boss variation they're
like yeah so the thing I mean when you
go through the escalation protocol when
you fought it you'd know the seven waves
right now you're gonna know the
encounters in this one but you're at
least not gonna face them in the same
order the waves one through six and
escalation are going to be the same
generally okay Ryan is a public event
that might pop in but those are gonna be
the same like wave six is going to be
the big dudes wave five is not quite
that you've always got the crystals like
that doesn't ever change this will at
least be a different order the
matchmaking is there so you've got six
in there and just the fact that you've
got the progress the times the triumphs
and then the boss the fight at the end
but boss mechanics were kind of cool so
far I mean for me right now I want to
see the bosses but it's probably gonna
be the best one easy so you've got I got
it above everything honestly right now
Oh
as I say because flight a agrees with
you right now he's like pending on
bosses being and like actual random
rotation especially but even then
probably still above it for something
that I will go grind out happily yeah
yeah and then I'm here and also like um
you know he's just like just a match
making itself like just having that
right is a huge deal matchmaking is huge
just like I mean that's the thing we
like we jumped into an encounter we
worked on it for a little bit not only
like three or four I'm like why are we
getting work and then I stopped before
once in the next encounter we waited a
couple people got match-made and they
joined for the second part you can you
get to start encounter their raid
banners at each encounter nice so you
pick when you start it the progress
works I remember pushing you to try it
the time is there but it's not gonna
like it's not a fail state yeah which is
good now heroic might be different those
might be like a failed States for
certain things but yeah like black wings
that are like menagerie feels like what
they learned from all of these that
excited me yeah I excited me now and did
what I like
if y'all saying oh listen it is that
good - what excites me is the grinding
excuse me for those roles right those
holes
the extra layer and then picking they
seem like they learn okay this is good
I'm excited I'm excited I got a trap I'm
bringing I'm bringing the laptop so I
got a I got that ten sixty you're not
gonna have any time to play man I got
two nights I could at night I can sneak
a little you know sounds like you might
be able to but I was like you doing so
much so I'll try so the other piece of
how that works and sorry I've been
talking but you know you played I
haven't hmm
yeah shout out to the sniper it does
have an amazing perk the new beloved
sniper that's actually what it's called
it's not being a little loud made the
perk on that one I forget the name
basically reduces flinch mmm
so that's their uh wait what's the name
of your sniper because I was getting
killed beloved
oh I don't got killed by that there's
sub-site but that's just just destroying
you right now I'm really relieved oh
girl that's the crew scible and but it's
uh maybe it's an old one Tatara some
Tatar gays yeah what's that one Oh Lord
I'm having cold sweats right now in
crucible with that cuz everybody's using
snipers to get everyone is you down
snipers hey that one man okay no it's
it's beast and I'm like shooting I'm
like yo where's the flinch fam and he's
still getting ass knife's all four of
them sitting down hallways and stuff
it's 40 I started that grind yet but yep
that'll be a thing yeah get in the
cruiser boom oh yeah shout out to my
service revolver down and shout out to
Long giving us some game right quick
getaway artist got it yeah it's really
special I think I played with on real
quick I think I play with triple-a last
night oh nice but I got it could be a
fake sugar egg is it is what is it is
he's right dumb right know what and I
gotta find out what is yeah yeah you
know somebody's fraudulent fraud misses
him or him
I was playing he was really good and we
won it was it was great cop could do
nice um so yeah that's most of the
Nazeri really cool and the end you get
to the chest now the chest interacts
with your chalice that you unlock
through the quest line now the way the
chalice works you start and you'll have
these things you unlock and they take
Imperials that's the
currency that you're gonna have and
that's just like stored basically on
your chalice so it's not anything that's
gonna take up an inventory slot the
first slot basically lets you pick what
you're going for so you got the purple
which you start with then you got the
blue the red and the green and in the
bottom left hand corner of the chalice
once you get the first thing unlocked
you could work on your upgrades so but
the difference is you can kind of pick
mmm okay hold on I want to talk about
this intelligently for a second so sorry
go for it I'm gonna put up dusting
request do so that's gonna be a fun
thing on screen sorry everybody but the
chalice has the top section which is
what you pick then you have the
specialization then you can pick your
master work now so if you're going for
the roles you can be like I want a
stability master work with I don't know
the middle slot cuz that's not what I
haven't unlocked yet so that's where I'm
kind of clueless and then top ones what
you pick yeah we're gonna get a little
bunch of music for a little ah guys I
hired a second let's go so once you get
in there then you're gonna be trying to
figure out like what do you want to go
for but there's also like especially
when you level up these Imperials are
gonna be as I was saying if you can I
don't know if you're gonna get a chance
to play but there's like only bounties
that are worth like your time to go
grind because those are gonna get you
Imperials and those are worth a chunk so
if you get time to do nothing else like
your Imperial quest and then doing the
like weekly bounties just so you can
actually get the appeals that's gonna be
crucial yeah I'm up to the part where I
have to get Imperials that's literally
yeah I didn't know what they was Lyria I
was ill I got a chance to play it was
like now you got to get Imperials to do
something for Carol okay all right so
chalice sorry I'm in here looking at it
okay okay so you've got purple rooms
that will get you as follows class items
submachine guns or sniper rifles that's
the first one you can get you can get
two
red gems will get you gloves boots or
power weapons mm-hmm now when it comes
to the gyms that you can on so you start
with just the purple gyms and the top
thing open that's the first things you
unlock and then from there you get the
decision in how you like level up your
chalice basically now you'll eventually
probably do it all over time which is
fine but you've got improvements on the
right that are power and efficiency you
get an additional weekly reward with one
of them second one is an additional
weekly reward and playlist activities
may now rarely award Imperials as
Imperials are a limited currency yeah
that one potentially I can see being
very important to do early so I got that
one
gotcha the third one in power power and
efficiency which costs 8,000 Imperials
by the way that's gonna be a while
weakly powerful rewards from the final
chest in the menagerie will now drop a
season of opulence mod that's how your
disability go for your mod so those will
take a little while to get right I seen
an extra mod slot on an ever verse item
my god I was like what's this up with in
period I mean opulence mod I was like
this yep and now it's it's only for
specific things now cuz they've added
year one gear with opulence mod slots
yep so that will be the opulence mods
that's how you get those but that's
gonna be a hell of a grind yes then you
have your rune bonus you got three
levels of that grants an additional room
from Werner 99 40s bounties and rune
finder consumables which you can buy all
the rune finder consumables you want
rune bonus to one actively slotted rune
is refunded upon looting the final chest
in menagerie so won't get burned as much
and then the third one of the rune
bonuses grants a chance to gain an
additional non powerful reward from the
final chests you won't get the high
level but you might get another drop so
I don't know if it's gonna be the same
drop you're going for like if you're
going for a sniper rifle do you get to I
don't know yeah it's a good point
it's like that I don't know how specific
that's gonna be or was just an extra
piece who knows then you've got room
compatibility and this is the other
piece now I spent some of mine on
compatibility one which maybe or maybe I
shouldn't have done oh don't know that
unlocked my red slot rooms okay so you
have to choose which ones you're gonna
unlock so the red rooms will do
class-specific arm and leg armor and
power weapons that's the one I already
did then the next one that's 3500
Imperials is going to get you hand
cannons sidearms and helms and then the
final one for 6000 is gonna be chest
armor fusions and shotguns okay so
basically you have some form of control
on what you're gonna do I want to go for
all the different variants well that's
where I spend it all first do I want to
be able to get more powerful drops first
that's your choice do I want the mods am
I gonna spend it do I haven't care about
the other gear right now or do I just
want the mods to be able to put another
stuff that's all the thing so your top
slot is picking what you're going for
the left hand slot is unlocking gear
specializations so unlock this rune slot
to control the specific properties of
the gear defined by the top gear type
unlocking this rune slot increases the
number of rooms or order from the
treasure hunt bounties that's fine so if
you're going for specific says like to
control the specific properties of gear
I don't know if it's because then you
have the master work on the other side
mm-hmm master works gonna be your master
work perk do you think you can actually
control the perks you're going for the
vibe I got was yeah you can cuz they I
remember what we did last lasso that
last table they said hey we're giving
you a one away handling on a sniper yeah
now that one you could pick like the
number one would be the sniper I would
put in the rune of jubilation it's a
purple one right and then the master
work slot when you figure out where
those go right there like okay put this
one in here but there was a third one
they said and I don't and that
specialization because you have weapons
and armor you can go for which is a good
thing by the way I wasn't sure if it was
weapons or armor or both so your
specialization is that gonna be like
your armor ammo reserves is that going
to be is that gonna be your resistance
your void are consoler
but I mean you have like you're gonna
eventually have 12 rooms yeah and four
specializations on armor 12 is
definitely
more than void our consoler okay so I
mean so is it like is it heavy wait is
it a mobility armor is it something like
that or did they let you get into the
nitty-gritty
when you go to weapons and you pick a
specialization are we talking about like
a sniper with a you know is it an
adaptive frame sniper or are we talking
about something with like snapshot
sights I don't know that one that's the
piece I don't know that's the one I'm
unclear as to how specific you're gonna
be able to grind mmm I just I just love
the customization I love hops Eddie once
you said you've ranked it over my
beloved escalation protocol I'm pumped
I'm phone that's that's high praise
coming from you because I love ap I
still would run EP you know any chance I
got so I'm liking what I'm hearing and
then I can trick to run with six man
just you don't get me in a mix and it's
trying stuff out man shout out to the
nerfs cuz I heard um died on my car oh
oh boy it's real just real tough out
here maybe I get new exotics got to get
new flows oh yeah but I can't wait to
try stuff out me anything you've been
messing any builds you've been messing
with specifically that feel good any new
exotics drop for you every night like
somebody I was playing with her saying
like are you guys notice Morgan's onyx I
have zero so far I've played a lot of
powerful drops not one exotic Oh goo
saying on that stuff so far so no idea
on any of that's their stuff so they're
saying in chat by the way the
specialization Christian and Klingberg
so thank you
it's just what type of weapon and armor
piece you get so like fire rate or
adaptive frame or something like that so
potentially perks they're still gonna be
the random pieces but you're just going
for you know do I want a sniper that's
like heavy or fast or whatever so those
I think you're gonna be your choice not
as much on like doing on snapshot so
it's kind of what I figure the random
roles would be there so that makes sense
clarification hopes though but yeah so
like the nice thing was having the
chalice I was going through and loved my
two lowest slots were gloves and boots
and that was one of the reasons I got
the I was lucky enough and I got the red
gym as one of my unlocks yeah I went I
had powerful gear and I was like I need
gloves I went and got gloves
and I got the power of of loves and then
I was like I spent some Imperials unlock
the second powerful slot and I was like
I need boots I have a gym that I ran one
more time and I got boots so guys the
fact that you can pick a couple like no
slots it's a nice way to help orangy may
have its moments and like I am
struggling to get a class item and once
you're leveled up it's not gonna matter
as much right as you're leveling and
especially if you're doing multiple
characters like man this one slot is
suck skirt I'll just go to the menagerie
and go upgrade this one right now you
can pick so leveling of other characters
will help a little bit - nice dude I'm
like what I'm hearing I'm deafening
that's being on that laptop so yeah I
think it's pretty cool all in all pretty
pretty kind of Awesome the best way I
can phrase that I think the question
that I think most people are gonna have
is when you get into what else is gonna
come so we've got a new boss the truth
quest and the new boss and the iron the
iron banner quest and the heroic mode
yeah so if you have three bosses and
then the heroic mode it seems like this
is a very front-loaded season yes yes
it's got the raid we got the menagerie
heroic mode as June lumina quests as
July 2nd and then we're talking probably
a lull in the summer season solstice of
Heroes is gonna be that grind then you
know but it's gonna go for but yeah it's
a very June is gonna be where it's
hopping and then you might have a little
time before September so is is my
feeling cuz once you you know if you
want to grind them all up it's fine but
if you don't obviously you may not need
to
but yeah you'll have you'll have
something you'll have most of its pretty
stacked in that first four weeks
actually hike man like what I'm hearing
opulence baby so yeah we are at two and
a half hours yeah well yeah we rockin we
rocked so it's been an awesome podcast
thank you guys chat has been amazing in
here before we go I'm gonna put a link
in chat and you guys can check the
description in a couple other places
this isn't for me this is just a place
for you guys to do it but as we're going
to Guardian con and they are already
supporting st. Jude's anyway basically I
just set up through
a link for me just because I'm trying to
help as well from my community his
donations to st. Jude
so like the amount that they have raised
before is amazing but two point whatever
million dollars they've done before I
just have a baby campaign but anything
that you guys want to donate to st. Jude
I've got a link in chat I'll have links
all over the place for about the next
couple of months just to see at least
through all of us through last word
through my community and if you got
anything in yours I can give you a link
as well just to see how much we can help
contribute to st. Jude because awesome I
mean when it comes to cancer for
children that's one of the probably the
worst things I could ever imagine
yeah and some the the effort they put
for words like the amount that they've
cured like going from 20% so like 80% I
just wanted to tell you guys if you guys
do want to be generous I know the subs
are really helpful donations are cool
but at this point right now guys if you
want to put your money anywhere donate
their you know help support that cause
I've got a link 100% goes towards the
st. Jude's Guardian Khan Fund so it's
all going to st. Jude's if you guys have
anything about that questions or
anything let me know but that is one
thing if your listen to this on audio
find me on Twitter anything like that
I'll probably have the link posted and
usually on the video version of these I
will definitely have it underneath so I
wanted to shout out and just say if you
guys you guys are feeling generous right
now share the love that direction right
now because they deserve it
so absolutely good good cause always
positive vibes man so India definitely
man any anything you guys contribute
definitely much appreciate it man great
cause but that's about all I got
we have probably filled your ears with
enough speculation about what is to come
we know a lot of what is to come the
cross save and everything is that's
propitious things the free entry is
really cool I'll come in Eris and the
moon just do we got we got a lot of
happiness and the next week is gonna be
I don't know how much more they're
probably gonna drop on stage with Geoff
Keeley I think in III they're gonna have
the they're gonna talk about all that
stuff yeah like deed you'll be in there
explaining everything that's happening
what's free what's common cross save and
all that stuff I just don't know how I
don't think there's gonna be new that
much new stuff maybe there will be
I'm just not holding my breath assal
they're nerds right now I think they're
just doing that on the e3 stage as well
yeah I think so I think that um but
again let's be honest they didn't they
don't have to go to e3 I mean this they
can literally finish this right here
yeah this is perfectly fine like there's
really no need to go so I think we get a
regurgitation yes ninety eighty to
eighty percent ninety percent I think we
get a few more nuggets as well that's
what I'm going with
but I think yeah this is gonna be it
like they definitely you know for all
intents and purposes you know shot the
shot with this but this there's some
stuff that I think we might get some
maybe a little bit more detail one thing
about Keighley he's gonna press he's
gonna press on certain questions he's
gonna ask certain things faced indeed
she's got the ultimate and ultimate
battle that's gonna be the battle battle
of marketing savvy versus interview you
know technique and guile is that's I'm
gonna watch the head there the
heavyweight Titans there's questions
more exposure get the free cross save
the stadia stuff that'll hopefully get a
bit more out there and I will see as you
said if we get any more Nuggets but
that'll be Tuesday I gotta look at the
time it's like middle of the day I think
almost dead center I think it's like
noon pacific 10 a.m. Pacific I gotta see
I got a rug I got like a my schedule up
and look at it because I know you'll
know
yeah media video man up so looking
forward to it well send this man some
good vibes out there as travels the e3
go smooth and all his conferences and
things he gets to talk to her awesome
get all your sub videos and content and
talk to all the people and network as
you should so tell them where to look
for all that future stuff that's coming
sir yeah man check us out my III iron
law podcast returns to e3 man so excited
my favorite time of year it's literally
the Superbowl of gaming as far as I'm
concerned so much fun it's all moan also
fraternal you get to see a lot of
friends and content creators that um you
know you interact with and get to see if
it's our yearly kind of thing and a lot
of it the higher-ups executives I mean
all over the place man I mean I met a
lot of bunch of guys there as well I
believe
Christopher Barrett you know teach the
list goes on you know and is it good to
see a lot of those face
oh yeah we're gonna be out there man
iron law podcast YouTube please check us
out we're gonna be doing a ton of
content some pre-recorded we're gonna do
some live streams we're gonna do
conference reactions you're gonna be
hitting up a lot of these stuff there's
there's the Microsoft's the Ubisoft you
know um who else PC gaming show we're
gonna be out there as well
sponsored by the epic store and um yeah
it's gonna be AMD we're gonna be doing
those conferences with the tech hey say
hi to deeds from her no I'll try to get
her get a hold of me I think Luke Smith
will be there and Noseworthy most likely
so I'll definitely I'll try my best man
it's gonna be tough to try to I'm a big
deal but I don't know if I can elbow all
that you know Secret Service out there
that's gonna be tough yeah but yeah that
that's a dream you know that's a bucket
list you to have an interview with the
place
if possible get some type of feedback
you not believe they're doing the panel
you know I'd love to ask them some tough
questions if possible but um yeah man
I'm gonna be out there so I'll check us
out I love podcast YouTube check me out
lookout needle on Twitter you know I'm
saying and also check out please check
out Lords of gaming dotnet we're gonna
be doing live blogging put a lot of
stuff up there as well and besides I'm
also gonna start putting the last word
up there as well if you miss it as well
as King doing king of the statues he's
got Infinity Gauntlet up right now man
check it out and see it's amazing and
the last thing I'll plug is arm for you
switch owners Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3
we're doing a fantastic giveaway please
go to Lords of gaming that net Goldie
the Ultimate Alliance um King I mean
king of statues and you'll see the
giveaway in there as well so check us
out man we gonna be busy but we can be
violon I got oh one less exclusive or
blockbuster that I can't talk about
right now that I'm gonna get to see
behind C's but man I'm excited
the minute I can get the lid off of that
one I won't be Engadget I'm not breaking
in to you I'll tell you guys exactly a
shout out to ingot breaking okay baby oh
but um yeah man independer said you
could just go ahead and give me a month
yeah let me put the liquor you check so
I check out king of statues while you
they at the bottom of the article you
will see our giveaway through green so
get in there get your shot to win it
it's gonna be the switch game of the
summer in my opinion I'm also gonna be
hitting that up to Nintendo and see what
they do they got a lot of good stuff to
show them yeah I'm happy man salute de
yeah throw-in this again thank you bro
one more time yeah throw it up one more
time all right that is the article and
it will give you the link directly for
the giveaway as a little bonus in it so
you guys you have that so you can try to
win it and check it out but yeah bad
that's what a gap mishaan de we did a
nice little impromptu we had tons of
news the last two this is what has been
it's been crazy in the world of gaming
keep your eyes glued on the internet
next week because it's all gonna be out
there this man will be covering a lot of
it for you so stay tuned and yeah I mean
I'm pumped excited and you guys know
where to find me
Twitter twitch right here YouTube if
you're watching me there if you're on
the audio platform kind of fund me and
come find me on any of those and that
just keeps growing as well so thank you
guys very much for everything
he Bonta CBO and t is google it you'll
find me GZ yes yeah but I'll probably be
streaming I do want to try and do the
raid this week and so I will I see if I
can squeeze that I wanna see if I can
get that jacket as an option I don't
know how much it's gonna go looks like a
nice one I might have to try and go for
so got it do it by the guy I want to see
you stream it alright well thank you
guys very much you guys have all been
amazing and for episode 62 for an
impromptu on a Thursday it has been the
last word